WHAT WILL GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED NOW -- THIS IS THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON CALIFORNIA
MEXICO COOPERATION HERE IN THE
ON THE STATE SENATE.
THANK YOU -- ATTENDING TODAY WE
ARE VERY EXCITED -- TO BE
CELEBRATING THIS -- VERY
MOMENTOUS OCCASION THAT IS THE
TENTH.
ANNUAL MEXICO ADVOCACY DAY HERE
IN SACRAMENTO.
I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY WHO IS --
PARTICIPATED IN MAKING THE STATE
POSSIBLE.
THIS A COMMITTEE OF THAT WAS
CREATED TO ADDRESS.
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUES
SURROUNDING CALIFORNIA'S
COLLABORATION WITH MEXICO OUR
OUR OUR COMBINED -- COUNTRY
COUNTRIES ARE COMBINED --
RELATIONSHIP THAT WE'VE HAD FOR
FOR MANY MANY YEARS. FOR MANY.
DECADES MANY CENTURIES ACTUALLY.
THE FOCUS OF TODAY'S HEARING.
IS JUST TO DISCUSS A GROWING BI
NATIONAL ECONOMY.
AND ALL THE DIFFERENT
OPPORTUNITIES WE CREATE BY
MAXIMIZING OUR RESOURCES.
AND WORKING TOGETHER.
THIS OF HEARING WILL PROVIDE
PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE A COMPREHENSIVE AND
ROBUST DISCUSSION. TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE CURRENT ECONOMIC
STATUS OF OURBI NATIONAL
ECONOMY AND WHAT ADDITIONAL
POLICIES AND MECHANISMS.
ARE NECESSARY TO CONTINUE TO
GROW CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC
RELATIONSHIP WITH MEXICO.
ACROSS OUR SHARED BORDER.
I'M VERY HONORED TO HAVE MY
COLLEAGUES HERE TODAY -- WE WILL
BE JOINED -- WE HAVE BEEN ALLEN
HERE WE HAVE A BLANCA RUBIO
JOINING US FROM THE ASSEMBLY
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY
AND I KNOW -- SUSAN WILL BE HERE
IS WELL AND WE'RE EXPECTING TO
HAVE STEVEN BRADFORD HERE SOON
AND MELISSA O'DONNELL.
AND A FEW OTHER MEMBERS.
AND I JUST WANT.
TO THANK.
OF THEM IN PARTICULAR FOR THEIR
INTERESTS AND BEING A PART OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND AND THIS THE
DIALOGUE THAT WE ARE ARE.
ARE ARE FOR ME HERE TODAY AND
THEIR INTEREST IN FURTHERING.
A VERY IMPORTANT RELATIONSHIP
[inaudible]
BUT MEXICO.
I WANT TO GIVE A VERY WARM
WELCOME TO OUR CONSUL GENERAL
MEXICALI ENOUGH ATLANTA THANK
YOU. FOR BEING HERE THANK YOU
FOR HELP IN ORGANIZE ALL OF THE
ALL.
ALL THE FORUMS THAT WE'RE HAVING
TODAY AND AND THE FESTIVITIES
TODAY -- YOU HAVE BEEN JUST AN
AMAZING PARTNER COLLABORATING
WITH WITH THIS LEGISLATURE AND
EXPOSING US TO THE ENORMOUS
RESOURCES.
AND LEADERS.
AND AND OF THE THE IMPORT
RELATIONSHIPS THAT WE NEED TO
FORM HERE TO A BETTER POSITION
CALIFORNIAN HAVING A AN AMAZING
RELATIONSHIP WITH MEXICO.
BECAUSE THAT THAT IS WHAT IT'S
ALL ABOUT FOR ME IN THAT
DIALOGUE AND I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU. FOR BEING SUCH AN
INSTRUMENTAL PARTNER IN
FACILITATING THIS BI NATIONAL
DIALOGUE THANK YOU.
I I'D LIKE -- TO ASK IF YOU WANT
TO MAKE SOME COMMENTS MRS
CONTROL.
PLEASE YES SURE.
VERY QUICKLY SENATOR OF AWAY SO
JUST A COUPLE OF MINUTES TO
THANK YOU -- AND YOUR STAFF
ALEXIS OF FOR BEING AT AN ALLY
AND A PARTNER OF THE CONSULATE
IN OF MEXICO.
NOT ONLY TODAY AND DURING MY
TENURE AS CONSUL GENERAL BUT FOR
MANY MANY YEARS SO YOU WERE
INSTRUMENTAL -- IN THE
ORGANIZING IN THE PUTTING
TOGETHER OF THE VERY FIRST
ADVOCACY DAY THAT ENTAILED
ALWAYS A HEARING HERE AT THE
SENATE WITH YOU -- CAL CHAMBERS
LUNCHEON AND VIP RECEPTION OF
THE MEETING STANFORD MENTIONED
THAT HE WAS SO KINDLY HOST.
AS WELL WITH THE CONSULATE BUT
HAVING SAID THAT WE ARE TRYING --
YEAH -- IT ACCORDS.
WITH THE TIMES THAT WERE LIVING --
TO INCREASE AND STRENGTHEN OF
THE VISIBILITY OF THE IMPORTANCE
AND HOW MUCH OF A PRIORITY
CALIFORNIA IS FOR MEXICO IN
MEXICO IS FOR CALIFORNIA.
AS WELL AS A LEADERSHIP ROLE THE
CALIFORNIA AND ITS ELECTED
OFFICIALS.
ARE PLAYING TODAY BOTH
NATIONALLY AND INTERNATIONALLY
AND FOR THAT WE ARE VERY HONORED
AND PRIVILEGED TO HAVE US A VIP
GUESTS WITH US FROM THE MEXICAN
GOVERNMENT.
FROM THE MINISTRY OF FOREIGN
AFFAIRS BUT ALSO IS YOUR GAS TO
SENATOR NATURAL AND ALSO A
CUSTOMS HIGH LEVEL OFFICIAL AS
WELL AS SOME OF THE MOST
RENOWNED -- MEXICO EXPERTS FROM
ALL OVER THE UNITED STATES AS
YOU WELL KNOW AND YOU SEE LEE
PAMELA STAR RAFAEL FORENSIC
HOSPITAL AND ALSO A SPECIAL
GUEST.
TED KILLED RIGHT SO WITH THAT I
WANT TO TAKE ANYMORE TIME -- MY
AND I WANT TO ASK -- LIKE WE HAD
A SCHOOL JONES THE DIRECTOR
REPRESENTATIVE ALL THE
UNDERSECRETARY OF NORTH AMERICAN
AFFAIRS HIS WHO SADLY AND
RECENTLY APPOINTED.
DIRECTOR GENERAL FOR PROTECTION
AFFAIRS TO PLEASE COME ON OVER
ALSO AND DOT AND SHARE WITH YOU
A SHORT MESSAGE THANK YOU ONCE
AGAIN CENTER OF MASS AT WHICH SO
IT'S AN HONOR FOR US TO BE HERE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATE ARE ARE THANK
YOU BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA FOR THE
INTRODUCTION AND A FEW JOURNAL.
I BRING A MESSAGE OF GRATITUDE
COOLEY -- BY YOU AND THAT WE
LOOKING FORWARD TO A STRENGTH
ANYTHING THEY'RE COMING YEARS.
THE NEW ADMINISTRATION OF
PRESIDENT LEPAS ABOUT OUR HOUSE
A NUMBER OF PRIORITIES THERE ARE
IMPORTANCE FOR OUR RELATIONSHIP
ONE IS.
THE PROTECTION OF MEXICANS AND
WE ARE.
VERY GRATEFUL FOR ALL THAT YOU
DO AT HERE.
AT THE SENATE AND ALSO THE
ASSEMBLY FOR OUR COMMUNITYFOR
THE UNDOCUMENTED.
AND FOR THE IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY
IN GENERAL.
ANOTHER PRIORITY IS A PASSAGE
CHARITY CATION OF THE US MEXICO
CANADA AGREEMENT.
THE AGREEMENT THAT WOULD.
REPLACE NAFTA.
SO WITHOUT FURTHER ADO I'LL GIVE
THE FLOOR.
THE BACK TO YOU CENTER AND WITH --
VERY TRUE MESSAGE OF THANKS TO
ALL OF YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE TODAY I REALLY APPRECIATE.
YOU'RE YOU'RE VISITING.
AND NAZARIAN SOME COMMENTS I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
PARTICIPATING TODAY IN ADVANCE
AND I WANT TO WELCOME OUR
COLLEAGUES -- FROM SOUTH OF THE
BORDER OF THAT ARE THAT CAME
SPECIFICALLY FOR MEXICO
ADVOCATES SAY DAY THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE TODAY -- TODAY'S
HEARING WILL CONSIST OF TWO
PANELS WE WILL HAVE -- ON
OPPORTUNITY -- OF FOR A MEMBER
DISCUSSION THROUGH THROUGHOUT
THIS PROCESS AND MEMBERS IF YOU
WANNA -- SAY FEW WORDS JUST
RAISE YOUR HANDS -- AND WE CAN
ADD TO THAT -- JURIEN OR AFTER
DEPENDING ON IF IF YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS AS AS WERE.
AS WERE WILL WILL GIVE IT A TRY
SEE HOW IT WORKS BUT I WANT TO
ENCOURAGE A DIALOGUE HERE SO.
IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS PLEASE
LET ME KNOW.
OUR FIRST PANEL WILL TALK ABOUT
DEVELOPING A TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY BY NATIONAL ECONOMY.
OUR SPEAKERS WILL FOCUS ON
PROVIDING SOME BACKGROUND ON THE
INTEGRATION.
OF OUR TWO COUNTRIES.
I'M SORRY OUR TWO ECONOMIES AS
WELL AS THE STATUS OF THE US
MEXICO RELATIONS.
WITH A SPECIFIC FOCUS ON ON
CALIFORNIA -- SO WITHOUT FURTHER
ADO I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE OUR
FIRST SPEAKER DR PAMELA STAR.
HE'S THE DIRECTOR OF THE US
MEXICO NETWORK AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND SHE'S ALSO AN ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR OF INTERNATIONAL
RELATIONS AND A SENIOR ADVISER.
AT MONARCH GLOBAL STRATEGIES IS --
MISS STAR.
AVAILABLE TO PLEASE COME FORWARD
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
AND IF [inaudible]
HE BEGIN WHEN YOU READY.
WELCOME THANK YOU GET IN HERE.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
WAS A FOR THE INVITATION TO
SPEAK BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY
AND I LIKE TO COUNT THANK THEM
MEXICAN CONSUL GENERAL AS WELL --
IT'S IT'S A GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO
BE ABLE TO SPEAK TO ALL OF YOU
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE -- I
THINK IT'S PRETTY EVERYONE'S
HERE'S PRETTY AWARE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IT SHOWED PRO TO
TO THE BILATERAL RELATIONSHIP.
HAS BEEN AFOLK PROCHE FOCUSED
ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY ON
IMMIGRATION AND TRADE.
A FOCUS THE BLAMES MEXICO FOR
THESE PROBLEMS DESPITE THERE
BEING REGIONAL IN NATURE.
AND A FOCUS IT DOESN'T SEEK TO
CREATE CREATE OF CROSS BORDER
COLLABORATION TO DEAL WITH OUR
SHARED PROBLEMS AND ARE COMMON --
OPPORTUNITIES -- BUT WITH LESS
WELL KNOWN AS THE MEXICAN
APPROACH TO THE BILATERAL
RELATIONSHIP AND THE WAY IN
WHICH IT ACTUALLY COMPLIMENTS
THE WHITE HOUSE IS LACK OF
INTEREST.
IN BILATERAL GATE ENGAGEMENT TO
SOLVE OUR SHARED PROBLEMS R TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF OUR SHARED
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR MEXICO'S
PRESIDENT ANDRES MANUEL LOPEZ
OBRADOR AN AMATEUR HISTORIAN.
THE HISTORY OF MEXICO AND ITS
RELATIONS WITH THE UNITED STATES
AS IT'S TAUGHT IN MEXICO IS IN
THE FOREFRONT OF HIS THINKING
ABOUT THE BILATERAL RELATIONSHIP.
SO WHAT IS IT THAT AND LOW IN
MOST MEXICANS THINK ABOUT WHEN
THEY THINK ABOUT HISTORY.
I THINK THAT THE UNITED STATES
TOOK HALF OF MEXICO'S TERRITORY
IN EIGHTEEN FORTY EIGHT AFTER A
BRIEF.
FOR THEY THINK THAT IN THE EARLY
TWENTIETH CENTURY THE UNITED
STATES CONSTANTLY INTERVENED IN
MEXICAN INTERNAL AFFAIRS. TO
INFLUENCE THE COURSE OF THE
MEXICAN REVOLUTION AND TO
PRESSURE MEXICO TO IMPLEMENT ITS
POST REVOLUTIONARY CONSTITUTION.
IN A MANNER THAT MAX SURPRISED
US NOT MEXICAN INTERESTS.
MEXICAN FOREIGN POLICY FOR MOST
OF THE TWENTIETH CENTURY WAS
THUS GEARED TOWARD KEEPING
UNITED STATES AT ARMS LENGTH.
AND TO PREVENT IS THERE FOR FROM
INTERVENING IN MEXICAN INTERNAL
AFFAIRS.
THAT'S WHY THIS PAST QUARTER OF
A CENTURY OF U. S. MEXICO
RELATIONS A PERIOD OF CLOSE BY
NATIONAL COLLABORATION TO DEAL
WITH COMMON PROBLEMS AND ADVANCE
SHARED OPPORTUNITIES HAS BEEN SO
STRIKING.
MEXICAN FOREIGN POLICY UNDER THE
LOPEZ OBRADOR ADMINISTRATION
HOWEVER IS A BIT OF A THROWBACK.
IT HAS MANY OF THE
CHARACTERISTICS OF THE PRE
NINETEEN NINETIES MEXCAN
FOREIGN POLICY OF KEEPING UNITED
STATES AT ARMS DISTANCE.
LOPEZ OBRADOR FIRMLY BELIEVES IN
THE IMPORTANCE OF BUILDING
MEXICAN NATIONAL SOVEREIGNTY AND
A TIME TO ME.
AND HE IS CONSTANTLY COGNIZANT
OF THE POWER DIFFERENTIAL
BETWEEN THE UNITED STATES AND
MEXICO.
AND THIS THIS STRONGLY INFORMS
HIS CONCEPTION OF WHAT A
COMPROMISE IS A GOOD FOREIGN
POLICY.
LOCUSTS OVER THERE BELIEVES THE
BEST FOREIGN POLICY IS A STRONG
DOMESTIC POLICY.
MEXICO SHOULD NOT WASTE OF TIME
AND RESOURCES MEDDLING IN WORLD
AFFAIRS BUT SHOULD INSTEAD FOCUS
ITS EFFORTS ON STRENGTHENING
ITSELF POLITICALLY AND
ESPECIALLY ECONOMICALLY.
HE ALSO BELIEVES THAT THE POWER
DIFFERENTIAL BETWEEN OUR TWO
COUNTRIES MEANS THAT MEXICO
SHOULD NEVER GIVE UNITED STATES
AN EXCUSE TO INTERFERE IN
MEXICAN AFFAIRS. FOR OUR
PURPOSES THAT TODAY THIS HAS ONE
MAIN IMPLICATION FOR MEXICAN
FOREIGN POLICY.
THE LOCALS OVER LOWER GOVERNMENT
HAS NOT AND WILL NOT RESPOND TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S PROVOCATIONS.
AFTER EACH HAS TO A HOSTILE ACT
A RHETORICAL OUTBURSTS LOPEZ
OBRADOR'S POSITION HAS BEEN
CONSISTENT.
IT IS THE U. S. SOVEREIGN RIGHT
TO SET ITS OWN IMMIGRATION
POLICY AND TO BUILD A WALL IF IT
WANTS TO MEXICO WILL NOT COMMENT.
AT THE SAME TIME MEXICO DOES NOT
WANT ANY PROBLEMS WITH UNITED
STATES.
PROBLEMS THAT MIGHT LEAD TO A
CENTER INTERFERENCE IN MEXICAN
INTERNAL AFFAIRS OR MIGHT
OTHERWISE DISTRACT LOPEZ OBRADOR
FROM HIS DOMESTIC AGENDA.
NOR IS THIS POLICY OF NOT
COMMENTING ON PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
IMMIGRATION POLICIES A PROPOSED
WALL AFTER CHANGE IN THE NEAR
FUTURE FOR AT LEAST THREE
REASONS.
FIRST THE NEW US MCA THE US
MEXICO CANADA TRADE AGREEMENT.
BEYOND THE VISIBLE OR NOT
WANTING PROBLEMS WITH THE UNITED
STATES IN GENERAL HE UNDERSTANDS
THE MEXICAN ECONOMY.
IS RELIANT ON FREE TRADE WITH
THE UNITED STATES HE JUST NEEDS
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION ON
MEXICO SIDE IN THE BATTLE FOR
THE RATIFICATION OF THE US MCA
IN THE U. S. CONGRESS.
SECOND ATTITUDES TOWARDS UNITED
STATES IN MEXICO.
MEXICANS DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN
UNITED STATES AND PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND THEIR ATTITUDES BUT
POLLS ALSO SHOW THAT MEXICANS
ARE NOT CLAMORING FOR LOPEZ
OBRADOR TO BACK. TO HIT BACK AT
TRUMP FOR AS IMMIGRATION
POLICIES HIS CALL FOR A WALL HIS
RHETORICAL ATTACKS ON MEXICO
THIS GIVES LOPEZ OBRADOR A LOT
OF DOMESTIC FLEXIBILITY TO
CONTINUE HIS CURRENT POLICY.
AND THIRD AT THE SAME TIME
TRUMP'S APPARENT RESPECT FOR
LOPEZ OBRADOR SEEMS TO
INFORMACIóN AGENT NOT TO
CRITICIZE IT MEXICO'S PRESIDENT
PERSONALLY WHILE HE REGULARLY
CRITICIZES MEXICO.
TRUMP HAS YET TO CRITICIZE LOPEZ
OBRADOR.
ALL THIS HELPS TO EXPLAIN WHY
THERE HAS NOT BEEN AND WHY IT'S
UNLIKELY THERE WILL BE A MAJOR
CLASH BETWEEN UNITED STATES AND
MEXICO IN THE COMING MONTHS.
HOWEVER IT ALSO MEANS THEY'RE
UNLIKELY TO BE ANY POSITIVE
INITIATIVES EMANATING FROM
MEXICO CITY OR WASHINGTON TO
DEAL WITH ARE SURE CHALLENGES
AND OPPORTUNITIES.
THAT LEAVES A LOT OF ROOM FOR
CALIFORNIA TO FILL THE VOID.
INDEED CALIFORNIA SHOULD TAKE
THE LEAD ON BUILDING A STRONGER
BI LATERAL COLLABORATION GIVEN
HOW MUCH MEXICO MATTERS TO
CALIFORNIA.
LET ME OFFER A QUICK REMINDER
WHICH YOU PROBABLY ALREADY KNOW
WHICH IS HOW MUCH MEXICO MATTERS.
TO CALIFORNIA BEYOND MEXICO'S
OBVIOUS INFLUENCE ON OUR
DEMOCRACY AND OUR CULTURE MEXICO
HAS IN STORE NEARLY IMPORTANT TO
THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY.
MEXICO'S CALIFORNIA'S NUMBER ONE
EXPORT MARKET TAKING OVER THIRTY
BILLION DOLLARS IN CALIFORNIA
EXPORTS.
THAT AMOUNTS TO ABOUT 17% OF
TOTAL EXPORTS THE CALIFORNIA FOR
CALIFORNIA.
THAT TRANSLATES TO NEARLY SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA.
MEXICO IS ALSO A NUMBER TO
SOURCE OF IMPORTED GOODS AND BY
FAR THE NUMBER ONE ORIGIN
FOREIGN TRAVELERS TO CALIFORNIA.
AND MEXICAN COMPANIES OPERATE IN
CALIFORNIA CREATING THOUSANDS
MORE JOBS.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY IS THE
CALIFORNIA'STRADE WITH MEXICO
ACTUALLY OCCURS WITHIN THE SAME
CLASSES OF GOODS.
MACHINERY VEHICLES MEDICAL
INSTRUMENTS AND ELECTRONICS AND
ELECTRONIC EQUIPMENT WHAT THAT
MEANS IS WE DON'T JUST TRADE
WITH ONE ANOTHER WE PRODUCE
GOODS TOGETHER THROUGH CROSS
BORDER SUPPLY CHAINS.
THIS IS PARTICULARLY PRONOUNCED
FOR COMPANIES IN THE SAN DIEGO
TO QUAN A REGION WHERE RESEARCH
DEVELOPMENT AND DESIGN.
ACTIVITIES TAKE PLACE IN SAN
DIEGO FOR THE MANUFACTURING
INCLUDING HIGH TECH
MANUFACTURING TAKES PLACE IN
TIJUANA.
MEXICO THOSE MATTERS ENORMOUSLY
TO CALIFORNIA.
SO WHERE THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
ENGAGEMENT BETWEEN CALIFORNIA
MEXICO.
THERE ARE MULTIPLE BILATERAL
PROBLEMS AS WELL AS
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WOULD BENEFIT
FROM DEEPER COLLABORATION
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA MEXICO.
SOME OF THESE INCLUDE MIGRATION
EDUCATION ECONOMY WHICH I'LL
LEAVE THAT UP TO MY COLLEAGUES
ON THE PANEL TO DISCUSS TODAY
I'D LIKE TO FOCUS ON SECURITY
AND ENERGY ISSUES BRIEFLY.
BEFORE I TURN TO THESE ISSUES I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE ABROAD
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA ON
THE POLITICAL HORIZON.
THE STATE OF BAJA CALIFORNIA
WILL ELECT A NEW GOVERNOR AND A
NEW LEGISLATURE ON JUNE SECOND.
THIS GIVES CALIFORNIA THE
OPPORTUNITY TO QUICKLY
CONGRATULATE THE VICTOR AND TO
MAKE IT EARLY OFFER OF BI
LATERAL COLLABORATION IN THE
AREAS WITH THE NEW BAJA
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT THINKS IT
WOULD BE BENEFICIAL.
SO LET ME NOW TURN TO SECURITY.
MEXICO IS THERE ANYTHING
SECURITY CRISIS DRIVEN BY THE
ACTIVITIES OF ORGANIZED CRIME
AND GANGS WHICH ARE CONCENTRATED
IN CERTAIN STATES AND CERTAIN
MUNICIPALITIES.
ANY HELP UNITED STATES CAN
PROVIDE MEXICO IN LOWERING WHAT
IS WHICH IS ONE OF THE HIGHEST
MURDER RATES IN THE WORLD WOULD
BE BENEFICIAL OBVIOUSLY IN TERMS
OF PERSONAL SECURITY IN MEXICO
HUMAN RIGHTS.
AND POLITICAL STABILITY AND A
FRIENDLY NEIGHBORING COUNTRY.
BUT ENHANCING SECURITY IN MEXICO
IS ALSO IN THE IMMEDIATE
INTEREST OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS NOT BECAUSE OF THE
THREAT OF CRIME SPREADING OVER
THE BORDER FROM MEXICO INTO
CALIFORNIA.
DECADES OF EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT
THIS RARELY HAPPENS. FOR
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA THE MOST
IMPORTANT IMPACT OF SECURITY IN
MEXICO IS DEAD IT'S INSTEAD ITS
ECONOMIC IMPACT.
IT'S NOT JUST ON THE MEXICAN
ECONOMY AND THEREFORE US TRADE
WITH MEXICO BUT GIVEN THE
INTERDEPENDENCE BETWEEN OUR TWO
ECONOMIES THE IMPACT IS ON THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY IN CALIFORNIA
PRODUCTION AS WELL.
WE KNOW THAT DEALING WITH CRIME
AND VIOLENCE IN MEXICO'S
ELSEWHERE ULTIMATELY DEPENDS ON
THE CAPACITY OF LOCAL POLICE
FORCES.
BUT LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
MEXICO IS IN NEED OF SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENT.
AT THE SAME TIME MOST OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES ARE PATROLLED
BY HOW WELL TRAINED HIGHLY
CAPABLE POLICE FORCES MANY OF
WHICH HAVE HAD SUCCESSFUL
EXPERIENCES AND FIGHT IN THE
KIND OF GANG VIOLENCETHAT NOW
CONFRONTS MEXICAN POLICE.
CALIFORNIA CAN BRING ITS
EXPERIENCE TO MEXICO.
INDEED THE SAN DIEGO POLICE HAVE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE TO QUAN A
POLICE TO HELP THEM DEVELOP
EFFECTIVE COMMUNITY POLICING.
IN ORDER TO REDUCE VIOLENCE AND
THE BROADER ACTIVITY OF GANGS
AND ORGANIZED CRIME.
THIS KIND OF CLOSE COLLABORATION
BETWEEN MEXICAN AND I'M
CALIFORNIAN LOCAL POLICE COULD
BE EXPANDED TO INCLUDE OTHER
CALIFORNIA CITIES AND OTHER
MEXICAN CITIES.
LET ME TURN NOW TO THE QUESTION
OF ENERGY -- I BELIEVE THERE'S
ROOM FOR COLLABORATION IN THE
AREA OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
SPECIFICALLY IN CLEAN ENERGY.
GENERATION.
UNLIKE THE PREVIOUS TWO
ADMINISTRATIONS IN MEXICO CITY
THE LOCALS OVERLORD MINISTRATION
IS NOT FOCUSED ON THE ISSUE OF
CLIMATE CHANGE BUT STATE
GOVERNMENTS ARE.
AND THIS IS PARTICULARLY TRUE IN
THE NEIGHBORING STATES OF BAJA
CALIFORNIA AND SONORA WHERE THEY
WANT TO REDUCE THEIR ARBON
FOOTPRINT BY INCREASING WIND AND
SOLAR POWER USAGE.
CALIFORNIA IS OBVIOUSLY A LEADER
AND GLOBAL CLIMATE CHANGE
INCLUDING THE INTEGRATION OF
WIND AND SOLAR POWER INTO ITS
ELECTRICITY GENERATION MATRIX.
AND IS HOME TO A WIDE ARRAY OF
COMPANIES THAT ARE DEDICATED TO
WIN POWER GENERATION AS WELL AS
BOTH LARGE SCALE SOLAR FARMS AND
THE SMALLER SCALE DISTRIBUTED
GENERATION SYSTEMS THAT PUT
SOLAR PANELS.
ON THE ROOFTOPS OF BUSINESSES
AND HOMES.
CALIFORNIA IS THUS AN IDEAL
POSITION TO REACH OUT TO THE NEW
BAJA CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT IN
JUNE TO OFFER A BROAD BASED
COLLABORATION AND LOCAL POLICING
AND EXPANDING LOW CARBON ENERGY
GENERATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
BEHALF OF REGION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
YEAH.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA.
THANK YOU DOCTOR STAR
[inaudible]
CLOSE.
OUR NEXT PRESENTATION BE -- BY
DR ANDREW [inaudible]
SALLY.
OF PRESIDENT OF THE MIGRATION
POLICY INSTITUTE IN WASHINGTON
DC.
PRIOR TO THAT HE SPENT SEVENTEEN
YEARS AT THE WOODROW WILSON
CENTER WHERE HE FOUNDED THE
CENTER.
THE CENTERS MEXICO INSTITUTE
LATER SERVED AS VICE PRESIDENT
FOR PROGRAMS.
AND EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT IS
ALSO HE HAS ALSO WORKED AS STAFF
IN THE US CONGRESS.
AND ON DEVELOPMENT [inaudible]
OF OF MIGRATION PROGRAMS IN
TIJUANA MEXICO WELCOME THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE TODAY YOU SENATOR.
I'M FOR YOU CENTER THE RANKING
MEMBER THANK YOU ALL THE MEMBERS
OF THE THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE -- I
WANTED TO START OFF A MINUTE
THERE'S PLANO CLEAR
REPRESENTATION OF THE COMPLEX
AND PRODUCTIVE LINKS BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA MEXICO.
THEN SOMETHING THAT IS IN YOUR
DISTRICTS THAT ARE AND THAT IS
THE AIRPORT BRIDGE THAT IS THE
CONNECTS THE ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I THINK EVERYONE HERE BY
KNOWS THE STORY BUT IT'S WORTH.
THE CITY YES EXACT AS HE BE EXIT
IS WORTH RECOUNTING BECAUSE FOR
YEARS I LIVED IN SAN DIEGO AND
TIJUANA FOR MANY YEARS AND FR
YEARS.
IF NOT DECADES PEOPLE INCENDIO
DEBATED WHERE TO PUT A NEW
AIRPORT.
THIS WAS A DEBATE THAT RAGED
BECAUSE YOU KNOW FOR ALL THOSE
THAT ARE FLOWN INTO THE SAN
DIEGO AIRPORT IT IS A BEAUTIFUL
BUT SMALL AIRPORT IN THE MIDDLE
OF TOWN.
A EVENTUALLY AFTER MUCH
DISCUSSION THE ANSWER WAS NOT
BILLION AIRPORT IN SAN DIEGO IT
WAS ACTUALLY JOINING FORCES WITH
THE ONE NEED TO BUILD A BRIDGE
ACROSS THE BORDER FENCE.
AND ACTUALLY CONNECT THE TWO
CITIES ALLOW PEOPLE TO USE
AIRPORT IS A LARGER AIRPORT
THAT'S RIGHT ON THE BORDER.
IN A VERY PRAGMATIC WAY -- ALLOW
PEOPLE FROM SAN DIEGO ACCESS
WHAT THE ONE ALREADY HAD AND
IT'S BEEN IN MANY WAYS A SYMBOL
FOR WHAT'S IN THE ON THE ONE ARE
DOING TOGETHER TO CITIES THAT
HAVE ACTUALLY DISCOVER THAT THEY
HAVE MORE IN COMMON.
THAN THEY EVER IMAGINED THE MORE
COMMON THAN I WOULD HAVE REALIZE
WHEN I LIVED IN THE REGION THE
NINETEEN NINETIES I MEAN THIS IS.
THE ONE AS BEING MORE OF A
MIDDLE CLASS CITY MORE THAN
INNOVATIVE CITY AS A SAN DIEGO
SANDY WAS BECOME A CITY OF
INNOVATION AS WELL -- AND WITH
ENORMOUS AS DOCTOR STAR SAID A
MINUTE AGO WITH ENORMOUS
COMPLEMENTARITY IS IN TERMS OF
OF THEIR INDUSTRIAL PRODUCTION
AND THERE ARE DE SO WHAT IS THE
SAME THINGS THAT ARE PRODUCED IN
SAN DIEGO ARE PRODUCED IN THE
ONE A BUT YOU HAVE DIFFERENT
PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES.
MAKING THINGS TOGETHER THIS IS
IN MANY WAYS -- AND AND AND
PEOPLE'S AND THE ONE IN --
INCREASINGLY TALK ABOUT A COMMON
METROPOLITAN AREA -- IT IS
FASCINATING TO SEE TO CITIES
THAT I WOULD HAVE THOUGHT OF IT
I BROUGHT ABOUT MANY YEARS AGO
AS BEING COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
TWENTY OUT TO BE ACTUALLY MUCH
MORE SIMILAR TO THE ONE THING
BUT BUT IN SOME WAYS. SEVENTY
ONE ARE MICROCOSM OF THE BROADER
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN CALIFORNIA.
IN MEXICO.
ARM CLOSE TO A THIRD OF
CALIFORNIANS TRACE THEIR
RELATIONSHIP THEIR HERITAGE TO
MEXICO.
THE STATE DEPENDS ON MEXICO'S
LARGEST MARKET FOR STATE EXPORTS
OVER TWENTY FIVE BUT BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR.
THESE ARE STATES ARE
INEXTRICABLY LINKED.
AND IF THE BORDER COMMUNITIES
ARE AT THE FRONT LINES OF THIS
RELATIONSHIP INDUBITABLY
INCREASINGLY ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S
TRULY PART OF THE BORDER TODAY
[inaudible]
ARM.
AND I WOULD ACTUALLY MAKE THIS
ARGUMENT FOR THE UNITED STATES
AS A WHOLE MANY INCREASINGLY WE
ARE SEEING.
BETWEEN THE UNITED STATES AND
MEXICO THE BORDER IS EXPANDING.
DETROIT IS IN MANY WAYS A BORDER
CITY TO DETROIT DEPENDS ON BOTH
CANADA AND MEXICO SAN ANTONIO
AND DALLAS OR CERTAINLY BORDER
CITIES LOS ANGELES IS CERTAINLY
BORDER CITY.
BUT ONE COULD ARGUE THAT
SACRAMENTO WAS ALSO BORDERS.
INCREASINGLY THE BORDERS
EVERYWHERE BECAUSE OUR ECONOMY
DEPENDS ON OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH
MEXICO IN VERY DEEP WAYS.
ARM IN FACT IN THE FIRST TWO
MONTHS OF THIS YEAR MEXICO WAS
AMERICA'S LEADING TRADE PARTNER.
HAS GENERALLY BEEN OUR THIRD
TRADE PARTNER SECOND DESTINATION
FOR EXPORTS BUT THROUGH JANUARY
FEBRUARY WE HAVEN'T SEEN MARCH
AND APRIL YET -- MEXICO WAS
ACTUALLY LEADING TRADE PARTNER
IN A LOT OF HAS TO DO WITH
ACTUALLY THE TRADE WAR WITH
CHINA.
BUT IT'S ACTUALLY NORMALLY EVEN
IN A REGULAR MONTH THEY'RE ALL
VERY CLOSE ACTUALLY MEXICO WAS
MOVED UP VERY CLOSE TO CANADA
AND CHINA.
BUT WHAT WE'VE SEEN.
TRADING CREASE FIVE TIMES SINCE
NAFTA WAS IMPLEMENTED A WE'VE
SEEN CALMER AND WE'VE SEEN THE
TRANSIT OF PEOPLE ACROSS THE
BORDER INCREASE EXPONENTIALLY AS
WELL.
WE HAVE NOT SEEN THE KIND OF
FEDERAL INVESTMENTS WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR BORDER
FUNCTIONS EFFECTIVELY.
THAT SO THIS IS WHAT I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT TODAY.
ALL AT THE SAME TIME ON
AUTHORIZED FLOWS AS WE WE HAVE A
FULL COMMITTEE TODAY AGREED --
THE CENTER ON AUTHORIZED FLOWS
HAVE ACTUALLY INCREASED HOW MANY
OF US HAVE SAID FOR YEARS THAT
ON AUTHORIZED CLOSE WE'RE GOING
DOWN IT WAS TRUE -- BUT WE HAVE
SEEN AN INCREASE IN CENTRAL
AMERICA NOT MEXICAN FLOWS IN
RECENT MONTHS AND IT'S
NOTICEABLE AND I THINK IT MAY BE
HERE TO STAY FOR A PERIOD OF
TIME -- AND SO THERE AT LEAST
THREE CHALLENGES THE REQUIRE
FEDERAL ACTION.
AND WITHOUT FEDERAL ACTION LEAVE
CALIFORNIA IN A DIFFICULT
SITUATION AS MANY BORDER STATES.
ARM AND WHICH CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA POLICY MAKERS CAN
PLAY AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN IN
PUSHING FORWARD.
ME JUST POINT THESE OUT ONE IS
INVESTING IN PORTS OF ENTRY AND
I DON'T SOMETHING YOU'VE WORKED
ON A GREAT DEAL HERE -- OUR
PORTS OF ENTRY HAVE NOT KEPT UP
EITHER IN QUANTITY OR QUALITY
WITH THE TRAFFIC THAT WE SEE.
COMING ACROSS PRETTY THE
COMMERCIAL TRAFFIC AND WE'VE
ACTUALLY SEEN A REDIRECTION OF
OF PORT PERSONNEL. TO SUPPORTING
THE BORDER PATROL WHICH IS
ACTUALLY SLOW DOWN COMMERCE
RECENTLY BUT THIS IS A LONG TERM
ISSUE -- YOU'LL HEAR I BELIEVE
NEXT ACTUALLY FROM A CUT ABOVE
THE SO I I WILL STEAL HIS
THUNDER HE WILL TALK ABOUT THIS.
BUT THERE IS AN INCREDIBLE
AMOUNT OF CREATIVITY GOING ON IN
UNIFIED CARGO PROCESSING WHERE
WE HAVE U. S. MAX AND INSPECTORS
COLOCATED TOGETHER TO DO A
SINGLE INSPECTION INSTEAD OF TWO
INSPECTIONS.
PRE INSPECTION BEFORE THINGS GET
TO THE BORDER HOW DO WE BEGIN TO
ACTUALLY MONITOR FLOWS ROWS OF
TRADE AND FLOWS OF PEOPLE RATHER
THAN TRYING TO STOP PEOPLE THE
BORDER.
YES WE STOP EVERYONE OF THE
BORDER BUT YOU DO A CURSORY
CHECK AT THE BORDER IF YOU'VE
ACTUALLY MONITOR THE FLOW BEFORE
IT GETS TO THE BORDER -- AND YOU
KNOW PUSHING THE BORDER OUT
BEYOND THE BORDER ITSELF AND
THEN USING NEW TECHNOLOGIES TO
DETECT CONTRABAND BUT ALL OF
THESE THINGS ARE STILL THEIR
INFANT STAGE.
THEY ALL NEED TO BE UP SCALED UP
SIGNIFICANTLY AND THIS NEEDS
ACTUALLY FEDERAL INVESTMENT IN
FEDERAL COMMITMENT.
SECONDLY MAKING ASYLUM
PROCESSING MORE EFFICIENT AND
TIMELY WOULD BE KEY TO DEALING
WITH WITH THE UNAUTHORIZED FLOWS
WE'RE SEEING.
RIGHT NOW IT TAKES BETWEEN TWO
TO FOUR YEARS TO GET ASYLUM
HEARING IS ALL ASYLUM CASES GO
TO THE COURTS THE IMMIGRATION
COURTS WHICH ARE OVERLOADED.
THERE IS A ACTUALLY A PRACTICAL
WAY OF DEALING WITH THIS WHICH
IS YOU COULD ACTUALLY HAVE
ASYLUM OFFICERS BY CALLING DORIS
MEISNER.
OF FORMER COMMISSIONER MINUSES
ACTUALLY WORKE ON THIS YOU
COULD YOU COULD ACTUALLY PUT UP --
ALLOW ASYLUM OFFICERS TO MAKE
THE DECISION ON ASYLUM SPEED UP
PROCESSING TIMES TO MONTHS
RATHER THAN YEARS.
I WOULD BE SUNNY MUCH MORE FAIR
TO PEOPLE THAT ARE FLEEING FROM
VIOLENCE WERE FLEEING FROM
PERSECUTION AND AT THE SAME TIME
WOULD BE A DETERRENT THE PEOPLE
DID NOT A STRONG CLAIMS.
I'M AND THE THIRD THING IS WE
HAVE LOST WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
PAST WHICH WAS ONGOING
CONSULTATIONS BETWEEN THE US AND
MEXICAN GOVERNMENTS AROUND A
BROAD RANGE OF ISSUES.
AND THAT IS SOMETHING THAT IT AT
THE BEST POINTS INCLUDED STATES
AND LOCALITIES -- ON EVERYTHING
FROM MIGRATION AND TRADE THE
PUBLIC SECURITY IN CHAIRED BY
MENTAL CHALLENGES WE USED WE'VE
HAD UNDER BOTH THE A BOMB OF THE
BUSH ADMINISTRATION.
CONSULTATIONS THAT TOOK PLACE
FAIRLY REGULARLY DIFFERENT
STRUCTURES IN EACH CASE BUT
THESE SEEM TO HAVE BROKEN DOWN.
I THINK YOU'LL HEAR FROM MY
COLLEAGUE DR DR PHIL BUT AS A
CUSTOMER THIS IS ALSO AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR STATES TO STEP
IN.
BUT I THINK PART OF WERE STATES
NEED TO STEP IT IS ACTUALLY OVER
TIME WE CONSTRUCTING THE
ARCHITECTURE OF THE BILATERAL
RELATIONSHIP BECAUSE WE'VE LOST
SOME OF THE ARCHITECTURE.
THAT ADE THINGS FLOW EASILY
WHEN YOU LOSE THAT ARCHITECTURE
YOU LOSE THE ABILITY TO RESPOND.
TO CHANGING CIRCUMSTANCES AND
YOU LOSE THE ABILITY TO BE
CREATIVE GOING FORWARD.
SOIN CONCLUSION LET ME SAY THE
BORDER REGION WHICH NOW INCLUDES
THE ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING WHERE WE ARE SITTING
IN SACRAMENTO.
IS ONE OF THE MOST NOT ONLY SAN
DIEGO ITSELF WHERE THE SENATORS
FROM BUT BUT ALL OF US HERE.
IN A WORD IN STATE IS ONE OF THE
MOST FERTILEREGIONS FOR
INNOVATION AND CREATIVE PROBLEM
SOLVING.
BUT A LACK OF PROACTIVE
ATTENTION TO THIS RELATIONSHIP --
AND SOME OF THE POLICY DECISIONS
IN THE DEBATE TO ME MADE ARE
GOING TO BE GETTING THE FULL
VALUE.
THAT WE COULD BE GETTING OUT OF
THIS RELATIONSHIP THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS FOR
BEING HERE.
OUR NEXT SPEAKER IS WE GOT A
LITTLE BIT ULTRA HE IS THE
GENERAL ADMINISTRATOR OF CUSTOMS
AND FOREIGN TRADE IN MEXICO. FOR
THEIR ASSIDUOUS YOU'LL THAT MANY
SUBSTANTIVE THREE WITH THE IDEA.
OR THE TAX ADMINISTRATION
SERVICE WELCOME HIS AGENCY IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE COLLECTION
OF TAXES ACROSS MEXICO.
IN ADDITION TO APPLYING FISCAL
AND CUSTOMS LAW.
HE IS -- THOROUGH PREFER HERE'S
A THOROUGH PROFESSIONAL
BACKGROUND THANK YOU YES YES.
LEE IS A THOROUGH PROFESSIONAL
BANCORP IN A FOREIGN POLICY AND
CRIMINAL JUSTICE HE REPRESENTED
MEXICO DURING MEETINGS BETWEEN
SPANISH.
AND ISRAELI DELEGATES AND THE
SERVED AS A DIRECTOR OF
OPERATIONS AT MINISTERIAL POLICE.
OF THE STATE OF MEXICO IN
ADDITION -- THE RICARDO WORKED
AS DIRECTOR OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS.
FOR THE MEXICAN ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE.
YEAH MANY OF US THE MORALE OF
THE NAY LUCKY ONLY CONSULTORES.
WHICH OF THE LEFT IF. ELEVEN AS
USUAL YOU AS SOON AS WITH THAT I
THOUGHT I SEE.
A A LOT OF THE FUEL SO YOU'LL
MAY IS THAT YOU CAN OF THIS IS
ONE OF BUT A LITTLE STATIC HE
THERE'S ONE OF THOSE WITH A RULE.
MAY IT PLEASE THE INTENDED AS
ONE OF LOCUSTS OR WHATEVER IT IS
A GIFT OF THIS IN THE GOVERNOR
WHO.
A IT WILL BE WAS THAT A KEY.
YEAH IS THERE SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR HAVING US IT AND FOR
BEING HERE PLEASE RECEIVE THEM
ONCE WARM -- WELCOME AND
SALUTATION FROM PRESIDENT AND IS
ANNOYED.
SO WHAT I LARA AND BECOMES WHICH
WAS A GOOD THAT ARE WITHIN THE
AND GOT LESSER SO AT THE
SECRETARY OF HOUSING.
LAWS IS WHEN -- A YOU SEE A
COMMENT THAT REALLY SCARY.
A BUT I'M ALSO DOES IS THEY BE
TELLING FOUR TIMES YEAH.
SO I WOULD LIKE TO TELL YOU THAT
FOR US IT IS OF VITAL IMPORTANCE.
FOR THE LISTENERS THE PRESENCE
OF A LOSS OF ONE US IN BOLD
ALLOW LISTEN OFFICIALLY THE
NICKEL MITCHELL PROMOTED MEANT
THE CONFLICT AND KINGS.
BUT WITH EVERY MINUTE OF IT.
THE BILL OF ATTORNEY DOES YOU
KNOW HE SUCH ON THE COMMISSION
THERE IS A LINK THAT YOU CAN.
YEAH BUT THE A FACILITY AND AN
OPENING THE FACILITATION FOR
COMMERCE ACROSS.
BUT I OUT OF LUCK.
AND DENTAL ONE TOLL CAN ACTUALLY
LOOK A SIGNIFICANT LOSS OF ONE
US BUT I MEAN HE COOL SO IT TO
SPEAK IN AND IN GENERAL TERMS
WHAT CUSTOMS IS TO MEXICO.
A LOOK INITIAL POLITICAL LEVELS
BUT BASICALLY IF YOU GET THINK
THAT YOU POLICY AND PUT THE
LAURA CRUCIAL TO MAKE.
WHAT WE GATHER IS 31% OF ALL OF
RESOURCES TO MEXICO SO WOULD HIS
AGENCY MUCH?
BOB OKAY SECOND VIA THE NEEDLE
IF YOU'RE A GUY WITH A PHOEBE
BUT I WILL BE SETTING BIT THE
END UP REPEAL ANNA.
SO SINCE ALL OF THAT.
SINCE THAT MOST OF THAT MONEY IS
REINVESTED INTO THE AGENCY THAT
SELF.
IT'S FUNNY BUT ABOUT THE GARY
MISTLETOES BASED ALMOST ALL YOU.
A COMMON PLANT THEM INTO WE PUT
THAT THE PHARMACIST KNOWS WHEN
YOU IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO US
THAT WE ARE WITH THE IMPORT
PROPOSAL FOR THE US. THREE
MILLION MADE THE QUINCY BE --
MAINLY WITH CP.
BUT I GIVE HIM FOR THE LIST GOT
THE LOOK AT HIM IF YOU GET THIS
BY JOKING POINT SO THAT WE CAN --
STRENGTH IN ALL THAT ARE AT THE
BILATERAL.
IS THIS BUDGET INCLUDES A
SIGNIFICA THE THE SPECTACLE WITH
THE BILATERAL NEGOTIATIONS AND
WORK.
AND THAT MEANS LESS SPENDING CS
GO E..
A ALL OF THE TENDENCIES THAT
TODAY SIGNIFICANT FITTING BC BUT
SOCIAL MYSELF TO BE THE CLOSEST
TOLD ME.
I WAS IN THE SENATE AND THE
QUICK A US AND THAT THEY NEED TO
BE BASED ON A RELATIONSHIP OF
TRUST.
OR DENIMS VS TODAY WE HAVE TEN
POINT EASELS GIANT UNDERWATER
WITH THE SYSTEM DATE.
THIS BUDGET -- WHOM WITH THIS
SYSTEM IN PLACE OF THE THE
SPECTACLE WINDOW AND WORKING
TOGETHER THE MOST I CAN MEET THE
ESTIMATE OUR LIVE THERE IN THE
SAUCE BUT OUR GOAL IS TO HAVE
ALL NINETEEN POINTS OF EACH
BORDER AUG NINETEEN POINTS OF
CROSSING WITH THE SYSTEM THIS
BUT TO CONCLUDE.
TOLD ON THE KEYS TO MY YOUR FOR
DALLAS IS TO TO SHOW NOT WHERE
THERE IS A THIS LARGER
STRENGTHENING OF BOTH
INSTITUTIONS WORKING TOGETHER.
THE BEST WAY TO COMMERCIAL DOES
OCCUR THEN WAS CONCEIVED B. AND
THAT'LL THAT HAS LED TO CERTAIN
AGREEMENTS WITH CVP.
DIFFERENT THIS DANIEL DOES MEAN
THIS YOUNG LADY THAT DURING THIS.
TWENTY NINETEEN KNOWS WHAT YOU
ALMOST ACTING SUPPOSE YOU ON WE
HAVE A LOT WE WILL LAUNCH
FIFTEEN POSITIONS.
A STORE BUT SIGNIFICANT BUT
ALMOST BY USES THIS WILL MEAN
FOR BOTH COUNTRIES.
THE SCHOOLS AND WE WORKED ON TWO
VERY IMPORTANT THINGS THAT DO
NOT.
LIKE -- ONE YEAH DOUBLES BASIS
TO DETONATE THE A ECONOMY OF
BOTH COUNTRIES HE FOR PALACE
THAT THE CONDENSER.
AND TO STRENGTHEN THE TRUST.
AB DAY THAT AVOIDS.
THE BUS IN THE OLDER SALAS AS
THOSE WHO USE THAT DRUGS AND
OTHER ILLICIT.
MATERIALS ARE PASSED INTO THE US
YOU CAN BUY CINEMA SO MAKING.
AND THE ILLICIT TRANSPORTATION
OF ARMS LOS ALTOS WELCOMING
SEALS WE ARE VERY CONVINCED.
THE GATE LOW'S ME MOST PROBLEM
MUSKET NIMALS ANIMALS BUT HE
SAID THE PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE
IN BOTH COUNTRIES TAMBIéN CAN
YOU GUESS ELEVEN MUSCLE SHOULD
HAVE.
ALSO HAVE TO BE PART OF THE SAME
SOLUTION STILL IMPLEMENTATION
THAT THE NOKIA AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF TECHNOLOGY
THING IF YOU GET GIPSON
KILOMETER RUN PHYSICAL FROM DATA
MEANS THAT A COMMONER BEFORE
EACH BORDER.
BY MUSCLE DALY SAID AT THE NOKIA
WE ARE GOING TO USE TECHNOLOGY
GOING TO RECEIVE A NON INTRUSIVE
TECHNOLOGY GIVE AYE LEE MEAN
THAT THAT IS GOING TO ELIMINATE
WHICH IN THE 488% LOS DIMPLES IS
BETTER BUT I AM.
GOING TO WAIT.
OF THE CROSS OF THE BORDER IS
THE BOILING COMMITMENT THAT I
THOUGHT THAT IS BASIS THIS CAN
INCREASE UP TO THREE FOLD.
LOPEZ YOUNG WOMAN SHE HAD THE
BILL IN A FROM THE MILEY
OPERATION THE COMMERCIAL
OPERATIONS OF THE ENTIRE
NORTHERN FRONT BUT I'M AND THEN
IF WHEN I STROLL THAT AS WELL.
TO MAINTAIN OUR LEADERSHIP THIS
IT WAS BUSY BUT IS WHICH IS
COMMON SENSE TO BELIEVE THE MAIN
PARTNERS OF THE US.
YES YES I A STOP WILL BE THERE
SOON THANKS TO THIS OPERATION
PLEASE HOLD UP BUT THEN WE PUT
THAT THIS OF COMMERCIAL LOOKED
ON ANOTHER VERY IMPORTANT PART
OF THE SOUTH BECAUSE HE COMMERCE
FOR PAYMENT OF A SILLY STORY FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN THE HISTORY OF
THE WORLD.
IN. TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THAT IN
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE X..
WE HOPE AND EXPECT ELIZABETH AS
SOON AS IN THE MIDDLE THAT THE
SOME WILL BE UP TO SIX HUNDRED
AND SO PLAYED IN -- BUT IN THE
STATION TO SYNC WITH THE
MUNICIPALITY ABOVE SIX HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS.
AB TWO THAT YOU ME SMALL
[inaudible]
WITH THIS.
WITH THIS IN MIND.
IF SOMEONE'S OF LONDON MEANS WE
DO MICHAEL C. B. WE ARE SPEAKING
THE SAME LANGUAGE AS WITH CBP.
AMONG THE CONSIDER US YOUR OWN
LIVING MAYBE ATTESTED AERATION
IMMEDIACY LOOK HE'S THE KILLER
SAID WOULD YOU THAT LOGISTICS
AND SECURITY.
IT WILL STILL WANTS TO HAVE CVP
HOMEOWNER KINGS YEAH LIKE A PART
LIKE IN ISRAEL BUT I'M MAKING
MAYOR THAT CAN.
BE AMERICA MEXICO LET ME LOOK
FOR MY SOON BUT IN MOST OF THE
SAME FORMATION FOR OUR OFFICIALS.
LET ME LOVE YOU SOON THE SAME
LOCATION OF AYE USES THIS AND
BETWEEN COUNTRIES HE YEAH MY
THINGS HE STILL.
AND I INSIST FOR THE LEGEND LE
CONTENT AB STRENGTHENING TRUST
ABILITIES AREN'T THEY A STATE
SAVE THE MY YOU'LL GET A YEAR AT
IN FACT A YESTERDAY SIX OF MA'AM.
COMMENTS ADAM ALSO STRUCK UP A
FEW DOLLARS IN WE HAD -- COURSES
STARTING FOR THE TRAINING OF THE
MEXICAN OFFICIALS.
THE C. B. AND GET IT THAT'LL
MAKE YOU CRY OF CVP OFFICIALS
AND GET AT THAT -- MEXICO.
NO SO THOSE SYSTEMS COMBINED
SEALS WE ARE VERY CONVINCED.
YOU'RE GONNA NUMBER I MEAN TO
THE LOWEST LEVELS THAT WITH THE
NAMING OF THE NEW.
OF MINISTER LOUIS.
THE RAIDERS OF CUSTOMS
THROUGHOUT MEXICO INITIAL
PROFICIENCY THAT'S FOR
PROFESSIONALS WHO MAYBELLINE
LOOK AT THEM IN FROM A HOLDING
TECHNOLOGIES HAND FOR GIVEN THE
CIRCLE FEDERAL OFFICIALS BECAUSE
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO CUT
THE PROCESS SEES.
ON THE LET THESE GUYS UNITY THAT
WHERE DISCRETION. FOR
LEGISLATION IDEA DEPEND EVERY
WOMAN.
IS -- WE'RE GOING TO GET CUT THE
PROCESS IS WITH THE DISCRETION
OF A PERSON IS IN PLACE.
CANNELLA SELECTING A LUCKY WITH
THE USE OF TECHNOLOGY.
ALMOST EVERY THAT IT WAS GOING
TO LOOK AT I WAS ALWAYS THAT
PEOPLE'S DECISIONS THE VIETNAM.
INCLUDED AMERICANS HERE --
INTERFERE WITH THE CAR FROSTING
OF MERCHANDISES LET ME LET ME
SHOW COULD IN THE C. B. EMBRACES
THE SAME VISION THAT CVP HAS
HERE IN THE US.
WHAT IS ALL THIS CAKE IF THEY
CAN BLOW THE SAYS WHY THIS --
EXAMPLE OF SKYBRIDGE IS IN MESA
ARIZONA WHICH IS AN ARIZONA MESA
ARIZONA EVEN TOLD ME THAT
AFFORDABLE ENSURE THE WE CAN
REPLICATE THIS.
INDISTINCT TOOLS AND DIFFERENT
POINT.
WHERE THE SHIPMENT OF COMMON
SELES AIRPORTS AND COMMERCIAL
AND FOR THE SOCIAL NEWS CAN WE
MAKE IT GROWTH IN THE US AND
MEXICO?
ITEMS ALMOST EXAMPLES OF WHEN
ASSEMBLY HAVE SOME EXAMPLES HERE
FROM SOME BUSINESSES AND IS THE
GUY SO I MUST ON AND THIS CASE
AMAZON.
BORROW A RADIANT THAT LITERALLY
MEAN TONS REORIENT THE FOR THE
INFLUX OF PRODUCTS HE SAID GET
IN IN MAY HE GO BUT ARE IN THE
STATE WE LIVE IN MY EGO AND I
THEN THAT ARE DISTRIBUTED WITHIN
THE U. S..
LET ME GET A COMMENT THAT LISTEN
I ALSO WANT TO TELL YOU FINALLY
THAT CAME MOTIONS THAT WOULD
ALLOW ME SAYS THINKING WE DON'T
HAVE AND PUT SOME.
TECHNICAL FORMS TOGETHER INTO
THE FRONT THAT UNLOCKED AND ALL
OF THE NORTHERN BORDERS.
ON THE BUT THE FEEDBACK WHERE
[inaudible]
WHERE?
BUT IF YOU BUY THE MINIMUM WE
GET THE RIGHT WHERE FROM OF THE
THESE PROJECTS OF CUSTOMS
INFRASTRUCTURE.
OKAY AND THE STILL WITH THE NEWS
MUCH HAVING TO THINK THAT HAVE
BEEN.
SLOW DOWN AND STOP FOR OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
IN IT WILL BE AT NO THE
PRESIDENT IN MANILA BUT SORT OF
ALL IN THE GOVERNMENT OF
PRESIDENT IN THIS MANNER SO WHAT
OTHER.
A MOST BEEN SETTLED IN AND WE
HAVE.
AN ELIMINATING SPEECHES.
YEP BUT HE MAY GET THEM INTO BUT
I PUT THE FOCUS ON ACTING
IMMEDIATELY LOOK PROJECT THOSE
OF US ALL OF THE PROJECTS OF THE
PAST I GET IT DONE IN MOST.
WAYS WE HAVE YET MORE THAN FORTY
TWO PROJECTS TOGETHER CAN WE
LOOK AT AN BALLOT.
IT'S THE LAW ALL THE BORDER IN
THE US IN THIS WITH ME LISTEN BE
DONE AND IN THIS.
BUT YOU GUYS TO KNOW MORE ABOUT
THESE PROJECTS IN DEPTH.
IN CASE ANYTHING IT IS FINALLY.
ONE OF FOUR MELISSA YOU MOST OF
MINE AND LOCAL PORTALS MACHINES
OF A WAY OF KEEPING OUR
BROTHERHOOD AS NEIGHBORS WHICH
ADDRESSES ATTENTION BOB RUSHES
SO -- SAID THE ARREST JUST
PATHETIC CONSULTORES CHáVEZ
THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION.
VERY VERY INTERESTING UPDATE
THANK YOU.
CAN I WE ALSO HAVE WERE VERY
FORTUNATE TO HAVE -- SENATOR
COSTS AND NOT REAL HERE.
IF YOU CAN -- SENT OUT.
A SEPARATION THERE I REQUEST TO
RAISE A PRESIDENT AGRICULTURE IN
THE OFFICIAL SPEAKER.
OF THE U. S. MEXICO AGREEMENT.
AND I JUST WANTED TO INVITE YOU
TO MAKE A FEW COMMENTS REGARDING
THAT AGREEMENT IF YOU'D LIKE --
HE HAS BECOME THE OFFICIAL
SPOKESPERSON MEXICO OF THAT.
OF THAT AGREEMENT I UNDERSTAND
IT'S YET TO BE RATIFIED AT THE
CONGRESS BUT YOU.
THE SYSTEM.
BUT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT IS
BEING -- PROMOTED.
BY A PRESIDENT -- MANUEL --
LAPICERA THOSE ADMINISTRATION.
CABLES I REALIZE HE IS WE WANT
TO THANK YOU MAY BE THOSE WHO IN
THE END.
OF THE AND THE FUNDING FOR NOW.
CALIFORNIA SENATE.
THIS IS A LIST QUE JEWEL SOLELY
TO LET YOU KNOW THAT I AM THE
LORD SENATOR.
PAUL SEKETIKA.
BY THE STATUS IN THOSE REPRESENT
THE STATUS SEKETIKA.
SO BECAUSE HE DIDN'T THEM BABY
TO THE I AM A RESIDENT OF THE
AGRICULTURE AND TO DISCUSS.
FISHING THE THE SETTLEMENT AND
RURAL DEVELOPMENT IS A CALL THE
NUMBER.
NINE ORDINATOR OF THE COMMISSION
THIS ARGUMENT THAT THE MIND
FOLLOWING THE THE THE MAC WHICH
IS THE ACRONYM FOR US MCA BOOK
BUT DOES HE KNOW HE CAN.
BUY THE PART OF THE SENATE.
HELLO MEMBERS TIME IN THE LOCAL
MISSION TO GO AND WE ARE ALSO
MEMBERS OF THE GOVERNANCE
COMMISSION THIS HE IN THE FROM.
AT THE END OF THE POOL TO
SCHOOLS IT'S NOT A LIST FROM.
PORTAL TO CHANEL CONSOLATION ALL
TWO MONTHS ADDITIONAL COMMITTEE
LOCAL IN THE LETTER THIS IS THE
LIST WHEN NOBODY COULD NOT AND
THE COMMISSION OF EXTERNAL
RELATIONS WITH THE NORTH
AMERICAN. FOR AN EARLY.
LET ME GET ASSUME THEY MAY HE
COAL MIGRATION AYE FOR THOSE WHO
MOVES TO THE U. S..
WHEN THEM AT THE MEET THE VIçT
HAS A NUMBER?
FROM THE RURAL AREAS.
A MAKING A WHOLE AND IN MEXICO.
IT INCOME POOL IN THE FIELD AND
IN THE FARMING AREA.
IT'S A SAID THE POLICY AND
POLITICAL OF THE POPULATION.
THIS LIVES IN POVERTY IT LOOKS
THE POLICY A LOT POLISH WHEN 80%
OF THE INDIGENOUS POPULATION.
THIS LIVES IN POVERTY
[inaudible]
A A LAB WHAT IS HER LOVER LEAVES
HERE VIOLINS.
SO BUT THE LISCO SO THEY LET ME
ASK YOU HARD OF THE CAUGHT THEIR
PART OF THE ROOT CAUSES OF
IMMIGRATION.
A IN A IN MAKING COOL UNDER
MEMBERS.
AT PRESIDENT THE PRESIDENT ON
THIS ANNOYING UP THAT WOULD BE A
LITTLE HAS.
WELL MONITOREANDO LIKE NEVER
BEFORE APPLE YET OLYMPIC INYO
BEFORE. TO SUPPORT SMALL
AGRICULTURAL FUEL THAT LOCAL TO
FIFTEEN AND INTO THE HAVE AS A
PURPOSE. TO TO ATTAIN SELF
SUFFICIENCY.
A SALE CAM DEALS IN AGRICULTURE
AND THAT MADE CHANGES IN THE
EARLY HE LESSEN THE GOOD IDEA IN
LEGISLATION AND AGRICULTURAL
LEGISLATION.
IN THE LADIES BUT I'LL COME AND
IN THOSE LAWS THAT AFFECT THE
THE FARMING INDUSTRY IN THE AND
MAKE FULL BE BUILT WITHIN THE
THREE THANK YOU.
MEXICO LIVE DURING THIRTY YEARS
THIS HOWEVER YOU HAVE TO REALLY
SETTLE.
THE DEVELOPMENT AND THE
STABILIZATION COULD NOT GO TO
MEET THEM WITHIN FACEBOOK SIMPLE
IN WELL WITH THE GROWTH OF OVER
6% ANNUALLY.
YEAH COME FORTH WITH MORE DOOR
THEY COULD SEE MENTAL AND THE
THIS WAS THREE THANK TO THE
COUNTRYSIDE WAS THE MOTOR OF
THAT GROWTH.
DURING THOSE THIRTY YEARS.
A ALL HE SAID THAT THEY HAVE
ABOUT. EIGHTEEN A LOCAL NAMES IN
MANY INDIGENOUS.
MISSION TO THE SMALL THIS
ALREADY AND THESE MARGINALIZED
MEXICAN PRODUCTION A AND IN
MEXICO.
EL CAMPO LESS HE WOUND OF WENT
THROUGH THE V. SAYS BUT I MEAN
HE PRODUCTION AS THE SECOND FORM
OF THE MONEY THAT COMES INTO
[inaudible]
A MEXICO.
A TOTAL OF A WHOLE ELEVEN
AFFECTED ONLY UNDER
MANUFACTURING.
IS DOUBLING YOU BOTH A LITTLE.
AND AND ACCURATELY IF YOU COULD
READ ME YOUR THIRTY THE LIES.
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE SINGLE WITH ME
ON THIS AND I THINK THAT THIRTY
FIVE FOR THE VEHICLE WITH ME
DOING THIS FIVE BILLION.
DOLLARS. THIRTY FIVE BILLION A
LOVELY MISS A THING DATE THAT IT
MADE ME JONES AND IN THAT ARE MY
SUCH AS THE MONEY THAT PEOPLE
SEND BACK LIVING THESES MEANS.
L. TO LEGAL IN TWO ZERO AM --
TWENTY SIX ISM [inaudible]
TWENTY ONE ORDERLY [inaudible]
AT TODAY -- YOU'VE GOT MOVES.
TODAY WE ARE.
A PLANT THE HANDLED WHERE A
PUTTING FORTH.
AB MADE UP WHERE LOCAL MESSY
I'LL THE FIRST COMMERCIAL
AGREEMENT MAKES IT ENOUGH.
TO A ELEVEN AM BILLS THAT MAKE A
ON THE WAY I'M CHANGING.
MEXICO AND BRINGING THAT WAS
BASED FROM AGRICULTURE THAT WAS
THE FIRST MAJOR PUSH FOR MEXICO
WILL CONFRONT BUT IS THE SOON.
SICKLE TO DEAL BUCKLE IN NORTH
AMERICA SO WE SETTLE YOU IN
NORTH AMERICA HE DID THIS WAS IN
SAN ANTONIO TEXAS SO PART OF THE
NAFTA AGREEMENT WAS A CREATION
OF THE NAT BACK WHICH HAS IS --
MAIN BRANCH IN SOMETHING THE SAN
ANTONIO TEXAS.
OOOH PLANT THEM MOST TODAY WHERE.
TRY TO SEE THE A THE OWNER OF
THE LAND PALANCA THIS SEVERAL
YOU'LL BUT I'LL CAMPBELL SO NOW
WHERE'S SO I'VE BEEN WRITTEN
SEVERAL MEETINGS WITH THIS WITH
THE SENATOR AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT HE IS ADVOCATING FOR
IS THAT THIS NOW BACK CREATION
WHICH WAS ORIGINALLY CREATED. TO
SUPPORT SOME OF THE DISPLACED
MIGRANT WORKERS AND THAT'D BE
EXPANDED BECAUSE AS IT STANDS
NOW IT ONLY IS LIMITED TO THE
BORDER REGIONS BUT AS SOME OF
THE PANELISTS HAVE EXPRESED
HERE.
THAT THE DISPLACEMENT AFFECTS
SEVERAL AREA SO WHEN YOU HAVE.
THE MEXICAN PEOPLE OF THE
AGRICULTURE STATES LIKE THE ONE
THE SENATOR REPRESENTS AND YOU
HAVE PEOPLE IN -- AMERICAN
MANUFACTURING PLANTS THROUGHOUT
THAT NEED THOSE THAT SUPPORT OF
THE DISPLACEMENT WHICH IS THE
REASON WHY THE BANK WAS CREATED
THEY ARE NOT ABLE TO ACCESS
THESE FUNDS SO THAT IS ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT HE'S TRYING TO
PROMOTE AS WELL HERE IN THE U.
S. THAT THOSE FUNDS.
AT IN THE CURRENT U. S. M. C. A
PROPOSAL.
IT WOULD HAVE TO BE DELEGATED
ONTO HONEST NINE THROUGH THE IN
THE PROPOSED TIME.
NO IT IS NOT.
CURRENTLY IT WAS DONE THE SINGLE
YOU'RE STILL PUSHING. FOR THAT
TO BE INCLUDED AS A TO BE
INCLUDED IN A IN A BILL IN
CONGRESS [inaudible]
A THE BILL.
IT IS A IT IS [inaudible]
A ORDERS THE LEVEL IN THE LOS
ASSUME THAT THAT THAT WERE KIDS
WE IMPORTANT THAT THEY MAKE.
THE RENEWAL.
OF THE OF THE NEW TREATY USMC I
I DE UM TOOLS THE DISCREPANCY
THERE DISCREPANCY POINTS.
OR NO IS TEN CUMPLE ONE IS A
FIELD.
WHAT DO IS A LITTLE MEDICAMENTOS
HE LET YEAH THERE IS THE
MEDICINE IN PATENTS THE WEEK YOU
INCLUDED?
THAT ALLUVIAL WELL HEALTH IS A
LITTLE.
AND WITH THE DEMOCRATS.
WHO IS THE MEDIUM YEAH THERE IS
THE?
LACK OF OR THE CONCERN FOR THE
LACK OF ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS
THAT ARE CIRCULATED WITHIN THE
STREET ON THE AND THE MAN WITH
THE UPLAND.
YEAH YOU AND I HAS FOR THE YEAR
THAT WILL THEY DIED THIS PLANT.
ONE THAT WITH WHAT IS THE ISSUE
OF THEIR REFORESTATION OF ONE
HUNDRED MILLION TREES.
AND IS THE MALEVOLENT.
WE DON'T THINK THAT IS A MILLION
LIKE THAT HAVE SPECTERS CHECKED
D. E. LEVEL FOR MY LEVEL AL AND
THEN A COOL IN THE YES PLEASE.
AND A LOT OF THE CHANGES THAT
THE THAT THIS LEGISLATOR HAS
DONE ON LABOR HAVE ALREADY BEEN
PUT IN PLACE BY THE SENATE AND
HAVE BEEN RATIFIED.
WHAT IS DOUBLE PLATINUM WE ARE
PLANTING -- WERE SUGGESTION WE
THOUGHT WILL PLAN DENTAL IN MAY
HE COOL AND MEXICO ONE LITTLE
LITTLE SEE LAW SCHOOLS WANT TO
RESERVE A MISSUS INTERMEDIARIES
FOR THE MONEY THAT COMES BACK TO
MEXICO SINCE EARLY LET ME MISS
US.
DO YOU THINK THE US.
THE WITH BECAUSE YOU.
THE DIRECT APPLICATION THROUGH
OP DEVELOPMENT THROUGH THE
GOVERNMENT THAT'S HAS BEEN ONE
OF THE PURCHASE YOU THOSE.
MEMOS IF THE STATE THAT IS
MEETING THE JORDAN THAT THE
LETTER.
DOLLARS OF MS US OUR MONEY
COMING BACK INTO THE COUNTRY
FROM THE US IS THE COMPUTER
THING IN SOUPS HE VIEWS BUT I'LL
THEN WILL BECOME THE
SUBSIDIARIES SUPPORT -- FOR
CONSUMPTION IMPEDIMENT THIS LAW
WOULD HAVE CLUED ME IN ANTHONY
HE KIND OF THE INITIATIVE THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO PUT FORWARD.
TO ACHIEVE WITH THE IMMIGRANTS
AND WITH THE MEXICAN IMMIGRANTS
THERE'S AN WHO KNOW ABOUT THE
THE CIVIC WALLS WILL BLESSING
THAT ONE PART OF THESE RESOURCES
COULD BE AND COULD SERVE.
THE BILL SAID THE SEVERAL YOU'LL
THE LESSOR NEVIL DIALERS NOW IS
ON THE USE THAT IN A MOMENT OF
THE RURAL AREAS WHERE THEY COME
FROM AND TO HAVE THIS MONEY GO
BACK INTO THE RURAL AREAS OF
MEXICO.
CITY FEES HELLO GONNA KILL BANK
THE POLICY IN A LIVE RAT IF WE
CAN.
OF THE OF THAT MONEY COMING BACK.
SEVEN BILLION.
THE IS TO LET THE BUT ONLY HAVE
THEM BACK IS SEVEN TO MAKE IT
AND THEN GO TO A BANK THAT IS.
STRATEGICALLY FOCUSED ON HELPING
IMMIGRANTS IZABEL BILLY SAMOSAS
OLD RECALL TOOLS AND ENABLES A
LAMBDA SAID COULD THE KENYAN
TOLD ME NEED YOU ON THIS.
IF THEY'RE ABLE TO USE THOSE.
AS WE ARE TALKING ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND MILLION PIECES
FOR THE MEXICAN ECONOMY IS STILL
WILL DOUBLE TOE HANDLE.
BUT WE ARE WORKING.
WITH THE BANK OF MEXICO AND WITH
THAT IN WITH US IN THE EVENING
TIME WALLS AND WE THINK AND WHEN
THE SECOND THAT THESE RESOURCES
THAT WE'RE GOING TO SERVE.
BUT I MEET THE HAVEL'S EFFECT ON
THE THAT THE WILL AND THAT
DILUTES THE THE NEGATIVE EFFECTS
OF THE TREATY OR THE POINTS OF
DISPUTE IN THIS DOUBLES LEGAL IN
THE C. C. VEHICLE.
BUT I THE LOSING STYLE REFORM.
THOUSANDWITH THAT THAT'LL.
THOSE RACES THOSE RESOURCES DID
SERVE THAT STATES THAT WERE OFF
AFFECTED BY THE TREATY
ORIGINALLY NAFTA IN MAY HE COOL
EXACTLY LOCATE.
ILLUSION DAYS HE WAS VERY
LIBERATING 5% AND OTHER LIFE
FORMS DATA WAS ONLY FOR THE
BORDER YET AGAIN SUPPORTS HIT
THE PEARLY DELUDE BASS AND 15%
FOR THE INTERIOR OF THE COUNTRY
THIS IS HOW THAT HE SUPPORTS
HIZBULLAH DELUDE PLAYS FOR THAT
ALTHOUGH FROM THE SAN IS PRETTY
WELL.
GIVE A LITTLE RENDON FOUNDATIONS
THAT.
ARE CORRUPT.
IT WILL PLUG DEALING WITH THE
LEFT FOR MORE AND NOW WHAT WE'RE
TRYING. TO PUSH HIM FOR THAT
SAME FORMULA TO HAVE.
AND OF THAT -- I LIVE
[inaudible]
JONES.
AND THE ATHLETE NEEDED.
LESS CABLE WALKER LESS KICKING
THE THAN THE SENATE THAT.
ARE GENERATING THIS IMMIGRATION
WHERE YOU SUPPORT.
FULLER AND 15% FOR THE BORDER
WHICH IS THE AREA THAT SAME
PACKAGE.
FROM AND TO BE ABLE TO ACHIEVE
IN THE ADIL THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE BANK WILL WE ACHIEVE THE
WELL THE WHOLE THING NOT THE NEW
FIFTY SUPPOSEDLY WAS IN MAKING
BUT THE BANK HAS NOT BEEN ABLE
TO HAVE THE POSITIVE EFFECTS IN
MEXICO.
IT DOES BLANK THE OPAL POOR NAME
AMEN IN THIS DOUBLES WILL
NEEDLES THOUGH IN THEIR LAST
OVER HERE ON THE LEFT WILL PAY
THEM HE CAN.
LEAD AT TEN UNDER AND THEY THE
MEXICAN THE MEXICAN MIGRANT UP
THE BORDER.
I WAS TOLD TO LOOK WITH THE SINK
WITH THAT WITHDRAWAL ACOSTA US
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
HIS FAMILY IS HAVING HOPE THAT
THESE RESOURCES THEREFORE FELIZ
HERE I WOULD BUCKLE COLLUDED
MENTAL IS SEVERAL YOU.
IT LEFT THE APC PILING
[inaudible]
A IT IS BY THE SOCIAL COMMITTEE
SAID THAT MAKING WHEN THEY
THOUSAND DAILY.
FOR CALIFORNIA IS THE MAIN
PARTNER TO COMMERCE AND THEY
WILL PUT THAT IS A REALLY LOVELY
LESS TRAINS IN THIS RELATIONSHIP.
E. A. B. C. BUT THIS TEAM A
LITTLE ME THAT THEN HE CAN LET
OF THE FOUR AND THE MAIN
DESTINATION FOR THESE MIGRANTS
IT'S CALIFORNIA.
IN THE TITLES IN THE VOTE IS.
WE WANT TO INVITE THE HOLDERS OF
THE FULL INITIALLY SO THAT YOU
IT VISIT THE THE CONGRESS AND
MEXICO AND AS SYMBOLS.
REALLY THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND AND TO GIVING US THIS AROSE
BECAUSE ALLOWED US THOSE
AGGRESSIONS WHAT A STARK YET AS
COMMERCIAL PRESENCE HERE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. FOR BEING HERE.
WE WILL NOT CONTINUE WITH OUR
SECOND PANEL TITLED A ROLE FOR
THE STATE.
BI NATIONAL ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
DURING WHICH WE WILL DISCUSS THE
ROLE OF THE STATE IN BI NATIONAL
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
FIRST UP IS DR RAFAEL FERNANDEZ
THE CASTRO HE'S THE DIRECTOR OF
THE CENTER OF US.
MEXICAN STUDIES AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
DIEGO.
IS A FORMER.
POLICY ADVISER TO PRESIDENT
POLITICAL THAT ON DR FERNANDEZ
ACOSTA IS AN EXPERT ON BI
NATIONAL OF BILATERAL RELATIONS
BETWEEN MEXICO AND THE US.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE WE
REALLY APPRECIATE.
JOINING US TODAY ON THE CONTRARY
SENATOR WAS WIND DESCEND OWNER
FOR ME 2% -- MY VIEWS ON TO
SHARE MY EXPERIENCE.
WHEN DOES MEXICO RELATIONS SIMA
A NEW ADULT OF CALIFORNIANS HI I
DON'T EVEN SEND DEAL FOR A
LITTLE LESS THAN TWO YEARS?
ON THE NIGHT.
COMPUTER OPENLY TWADDLE KATE FOR
A STRONGER RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA AND MEXICO.
I DO BELIEVE ON THAT ISN'T MY
ARGUMENT THAT THE TRUMP WHITE
HOUSE REPRESENTS AN OPPORTUNITY.
FOR CALIFORNIA MEXICO TO
STRENGTHEN.
IT'S CONNECTIONS SO WHY ARE
AMONG THE SAYING THESE.
OLD BECAUSE SO.
THE MEXICAN STRATEGY -- THE
MEXICAN DIPLOMATIC STRATEGY
DURING THE LAST -- TWENTY FIVE
YEARS.
HAD BEEN TO CONCENTRATE
RELATIONS AT THE TOP THE MOST
IMPORTANT DECISIONS WERE MADE AT
THE TOP UP BASIC ELEVATED TO BY
THE TWO PRESIDENTS.
NAFTA.
CAME ABOUT.
IN A IN A DIVERSE CONVERSATION
BETWEEN BIRTH FORTY FIRST AND
CAL SELLING THAT IT WORKED OUT.
I'M JUST TO TO ILLUSTRATE MY
POINT LET ME SHARE WITH YOU AN
ANECDOTE THAT I THAT I BELIEVE --
WORKING FOR PRISON BECAUSE THEY
DON'T.
WHAT PRESIDENT OBAMA BE IT WAS
PROCEED PRESIDENT ELECT EVERY
SINGLE FOR EITHER WAS TRYING TO
GET TOGETHER WITH HIM AT THE
TIME HE WAS?
THE SINGLE MOST POPULAR
POLITICIAN IN THE WORLD I WOULD
PUT IT THAT WAY [inaudible]
THE ONLY.
POORLY THE WHO WAS ABLE. TO GET
TOGETHER WITH PRESIDENT ELECT
OBAMA WAS PHILIP BECAUSE IT'LL
FROM MEXICO.
THAT HAPPENS A ONLY NINE DAYS
BEFORE INTEGRATION AND I
REMEMBER VIVIDLY THAT THEY OBAMA
WAS VERY GRACIOUS HE CAME TO BE
SAID PRESSING CALDERON OF THE
MEXICAN CULTURAL INSTITUTE IN
WASHINGTON.
THE COVER LAUNCH THAT WENT OVER.
ALMOST TWO HOURS ON THE PRISON
CALDERON CAME OUT OF THE MEETING
VERY HAPPY AND HE TOLD US WHEN
WE WERE PREPARING HE FORTY PRESS
CONFERENCE.
YOU KNOW BARACK A NIGHT WHEN HE
SAID BARAK WE CERTAINLY REALIZED
THAT I WOULD MISSION THAT
MISSION ACCOMPLISHED.
BECAUSE THE IDEA OF THE MEETINGS
IS THAT THEY BASICALLY NEW
CHARTER THAT THE CREATE THE
PERSONAL RELATIONSHIP AND THE
CALL.
TO TALK TO THE RENTALS WE FIND
OUT DURING THE MEETING THAT WE
BOTH ARE LEFT HANDED.
AND THAT WE BOUGHT.
OUR LAWYERS THAT WE WENT TO
HARVARD AND THAT OUR SPOUSES
MARGARITA MICHELLE OUR DAUGHTER
AND BOTH WERE DONE HOUSE.
THAT HE'S.
VERY KEEN.
BECAUSE THANKS TO THAT THEY WERE
ABLE TO COOLEY CHILDREN ALL THE
TIME AND BELIEVE ME THAT HELP US
OUT WILL THAT CANNOT HAPPEN WITH
MR TRUMP.
ASK PRIME MINISTER TRUDEAU.
OSCAR THE PRESIDENT OF FRANCE
EMERALD ACROSS I MEAN IT'S VERY
HARD. TO GET TOGETHER WITH HIM
AND HE'S.
IN A WAY.
READ DR I WOULD PUT IT THAT WAY
SO WHAT IS.
WHAT MEXICO SHOULD DO?
VERY SIMPLE IS TO PAY THE
DECENTRALIZE GAME.
OF AMERICAN POLITICS.
IN THAT THE CENTRAL IS GAME
CALIFORNIA'S SEKI OCTOBER ON A
WOULD SAY THAT THERE'S SUCH AN
ENORMOUS OPPORTUNITY FOR MEXICO
CALIFORNIA TO STRENGTHEN.
THE ELATIONSHIP NOT ONLY THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS BECOME A VERY
PROGRESSIVE -- STATE AND I WOULD
SAY.
CALIFORNIA HAS BECOME VERY
PROGRESSIVE BECAUSE JUNE LATINO
POLITICIANS BECAUSE YOU LET THE
NO.
A LEGISLATORS UP SEVENTY YEARS
AGO WHEN V<c.cyan> BOLD WAS FIRST</c>
ELECTED TO CONGRESS I WILL TAKE.
YOU LET THE NO -- BECAME
EMPOWERED IN THE SERVER IN THE
STATE OF THANKS TO YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA'S PRE PROGRESSIVE I
BELIEVE.
THAT EACH ONE OF YOU ARE PUTTING
A VERY FIGHT VERY STRONG FIVE
PIECE OF THE TO TRUMP.
SOME POLICIES BECAUSE I KNOW
PEOPLE HAVE UNIVERSITA LIKE
MEDINA TOLD US WHAT YOU WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOUR CHILDREN.
OR YOU GOT CHILDREN THEY DON'T
THEY WILL NOT BE SUBJECT TO THE
PROBLEMS.
THE DISCRIMINATION YOU WERE
SUBJECT WHEN YOU WHICH SOLD I
BELIEVE THAT IN THAT SENSE
CALIFORNIA'S AND NATURAL PARTED
TO MEXICAN IMMIGRATION ISSUES.
IN MEXICO I WOULD SAY WE'VE BEEN
UP WITH THE ELECTION OF UNDER IS
A NEW LOW PURSUE A LITTLE WE ON
THE WINTER POLITICAL TO NOT ME --
BUT THIS IS THE VERY FIRST TIME
EVER THAT A LEFTIST POLITICIAN
IS ELECTED TO OFFICE.
AND THEN THERE IS MINERAL
PERSONA Là ASPIRINS
INTELLECTUALS WEEKS INTO HE'S
BEING PRESIDENT ELECT HE MERRY
HE MADE IT MADE YOUR DECISION.
REPORTING POLICY DECISION ON AN
ECONOMIC POLICY DECISION THAT TO
ME HAS BEEN THE BEST SO FAR.
SINCE HE WAS ELECTED PRESIDENT
HE DECIDED TO BUCK THE NAFTA
RENEGOTIATION.
ON BECAUSE BUT DIDN'T THE PINION
MINISTRATION THE BINNYA OPINION
IF THE MUSICIAN WAS ABLE CLOSE --
THE NOT THE RENEGOTIATION AND
AND NOW WE HAVE THE US MCA.
THAT IS A VERY IMPORTANT
AGREEMENT BECAUSE IF WE ARE ABLE.
TO GET THE THREE CONGRESS TO
BUZZ YOU AGREEMENT I BELIEVE
THAT THE AGREEMENT WILL HELP.
A LOT.
THE INTEGRATION BETWEEN CON
OTHER MEXICAN DID YOU.
HE WE HELP THE AGREEMENT I WOULD
SAY.
THE INTEGRATION OF MEXICAN THE
US.
WILL BE MUCH STRONGER AND WILL
BE MORE UPON ALMOST ALL OF THE
WHEEL OF PRESIDENT TRUMP OR EVEN
PRESSING Là SODA.
THAT IS WHY AGREEMENTS ARE FOR
BECAUSE THEN WOULD NOT DEPEND SO
MUCH ON THE WHEELS.
OFF OF A PERSON AND I BELIEVE
THAT WE BADLY NEED YOU D. D. U.
S. M. C. EIGHT TO BE.
RATIFIED TO BE APPROVED BY
CONGRESS I BELIEVE THE
CALIFORNIA COULD PLAY A PIVOTAL
ROLE IN THE NIGHT LET ME FINISH
MY MIGHT -- TESTIMONY BY BY
PRESENTED YOU I WOULD SAY WITH --
THREE PROPOSALS NUMBER ONE IS
ALI FORCED THE CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIANS SPECIALLY THE
CALIFORNIA SENATE AND ASSEMBLY.
TO HELP GIVE THE RATIFICATION OF
NAFTA THESE THESE WOULD BE FOR
THE WELL BEING OF MEXICANS AND
AMERICANS AND CANADIANS.
AND I HOPE IT ALSO WILL BE FOR
THE WELLBEING OF CENTRAL
AMERICANS I BELIEVE THAT WE
REALLY HAVE TO PUT A WE'RE A
TOGETHER REGARDING THE NORDEN
TRIANGLE OFTEN TELL THEM.
SECOND I WILL. FOR CALIFORNIA
AND I KNOW AND I KNOW YOU SAID
NOT TO WEAR SO YOU HAVE BEEN A
CHAMPION.
IN OTHER CREATING FOUR NEW
MECHANISMS OF CONSULTATION
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA MEXICO YOU'RE
ADVOCATING FOR A NEW COMMISSION.
I BELIEVE ALSO THAT HE THESE
WOULD BE THE TIME. TO CALM CALM
WHAT AGAIN ONCE AGAIN.
WITH THE THREE CALIFORNIA'S
COMMISSION SEEMS TO ME THAT
NOWADAYS WOULD REALLY HAVE TO
PUT AWAY DOCTOR BECAUSE THEY
WOULD HAVE THESE MECHANISMS TO
BETTER COORDINATE. TO BETTER
COOPERATE AND ON TO COUGH UP A
MECHANISM TO TALK TO EACH OTHER
WE NEED TO HAVE THIS QUOTE COSTA
DIE AND THERE'S IN BAJA
CALIFORNIA THERE'S A COMMON
ELECTION.
NEXT JUNE SECOND AND SEES TO ME
THAT THESE THESE WOULD BE A VERY
GOOD MOMENT.
FORTIFIED ON TO COME ONCE AGAIN
WITH THIS THE HEAD THREE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION BECAUSE
SEEMS TO ME THAT WE COULD -- WE
COULD ADVANCE HELLO -- AMONG THE
THREE CALIFORNIA'S AND FINALLY
LET ME COME TO A LOCAL ISSUE.
AT THE CENTER OF HIS MATERNAL
STORIES DURING THE LAST FIVE
YEARS -- OF MY THE D. ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR MILES'S OF LOCUSTS
SHE'S BEEN DOING THESE WONDERFUL
RESEARCH THAT WE CALLED.
THE STUDENTS WE SHARE WHAT WE
HAVE FOUND OUT THERE THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF STUDENTS THAT
WE SURE FOR EXAMPLE.
WHEN WE PAULINE AND WE DO THIS
WITH STUDENTS FROM YOU?
YOU SEE IS THE WE KNOW THAT.
IN SELDOM SAN DIEGO ONE OUT OF
FIVE STUDENTS THE COPS HOME --
EXPERIENCE IN.
EDUCATION ACROSS THE BORDER.
NINETY ONE I WILL REPORT INSTANT
WE KNOW THAT ONE OUT OF TEN
STUDENTS THE CUFF FROM
EXPERIENCE.
IN EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA SO
THERE IS LITERALLY I MEAN WE
CONCENTRATE.
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE CONCENTRATE.
A VERY LARGE NUMBERS OF STUDENTS
THAT WE SHARE THEY ARE BI
LINGUAL THEY FEEL BI NATIONAL.
GUESS WHAT.
THEY DON'T GET EIGHTEEN THE
EDUCATION OF THE NEED TO BE CALM
THE WAR FORCE THAT WE NEED WHY
BECAUSE THE BORDER IS VERY HEAVY
INTO HIMSELF EDUCATION.
BECAUSE OF NAFTA WE LEARNED HOW
TO BUTTE PRODUCE ACOSTA ACROSS
THE BORDER.
LEARN HOW TO BETTER ROUTE.
STRAIGHT ACROSS THE BORDER AND
WE HAVE TO DO DOT.
PREDICATION SO I BELIEVE THAT WE
HAVE A LOT OF POTENTIAL.
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AND MEXICO
AND SEEMS TO ME THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS GIVEN OF AN
ENORMOUS OPPORTUNITY TO
STRENGTHEN.
OUR RELATIONSHIP AND I AGAIN.
REYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THE U.
LATINO [inaudible]
THE POLITICIANS POLICY MAKER.
YOU YOU. TWO IN A WONDERFUL JOB
IN IN IN MAKING SURE THAT
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO BE A
VERY PROGRESSIVE THE STATE AND
HE'S HELPING [inaudible]
MEXICANS.
OLD CONDITIONS IT DOESN'T MATTER
IF YOU HAVE TO COME DOCUMENTS.
OUR STATE.
I WILL STOP HERE ON A YOU CAN
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY BEFORE REDUCE.
SEN THE DESCENT OF COMMISSION
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY FISHING YOU BEING
HERE AND ENSURING THOSE COMMENTS
JUST -- IT'S IT'S AMAZING THE
HISTORY OF THE AMERICAS IS IS
VERY SIMILAR.
AND THERE THERE HAVE BEEN.
OVER THE OVER THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE AMERICAS A LOT OF EUROPEAN.
INFLUENCE AND HOW THE AMERICANS
WERE DEVELOPED AND IT'S VERY
INTERESTING TO ME THAT.
A LOT OF THIS WAS EUROPE.
FIGHTING WITH EACH OTHER AND
STILL EXPAND FINDING -- MARKETS
TO EXPAND AND BAD WHAT'S MOST
INTERESTING MEETING OVER THE
COURSE OF HISTORY.
EUROPE UNITED IN CREATED ONE
ECONOMY WITH THE EUROPEAN UNION.
AND WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE STRUGGLING
TO DO THAT EVEN AT THE SMALLEST
LEVEL WHICH IS NAFTA.
AND AND AND I I THINK I JUST
GENERALLY BELIEVE MORE CAN BE
DONE IN THAT AREA I THINK --
WHAT WERE WERE VERY WEAK WEAK
AND HOW IT WE'VE UNITED OUR
ECONOMIES [inaudible]
BUT CURRENTLY.
YOU HAVE YOU HAVE.
CHINA MAKING AN ENORMOUS INROADS.
IN REACHING OUT TO A LOT OF
LATIN AMERICAN COUNTRIES
INCLUDING MEXICO IN TRYING TO
EXPAND THEIR MARKETS AND WERE
NOT REALLY TAKING ADVANTAGE.
A VERY CLOSE PARTNERS IN VERY
CLOSE ALLIES.
AND AND WHAT WE CAN DO TO
BENEFIT FROM OUR GEOGRAPHICAL
PROXIMITY. TWO TWO VERY BIG
ECONOMIC ALLIES AND I JUST THINK
IT'S IT'S IT'S IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY LOST.
BUT WE NEED TO DO MORE -- TO TO
BRING ATTENTION TO THAT AND ALSO
SEE WHERE WE CAN.
BENEFIT FROM THAT RELATIONSHIP I
THINK -- I I YOU KNOW THE IDEA
OF EXPANDING THE BANK AND MAKING
INVESTMENTS AND UNDERSERVED
AREAS IN MEXICO I THINK THAT'S A
VERY WORTHY WORTHY GOAL THAN IT
WOULD.
REAP ENORMOUS BENEFITS TO
AMERICA'S WELL THOSE ARE THE
THOSE SEEM LIKE INITIATIVES THAT
WOULD.
HELP US AS MUCH AS MEXICO AND
THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT OF THIS
DIALOGUE IN THIS RELATIONSHIP.
HOW CAN WE COMBINE OUR EFFORTS
TO BUILD OUR RESPECTIVE
ECONOMIES HOW HOW DO WE GET
<c.cyan>0C WE BUILD?</c>
WEALTHY CALIFORNIA HOW CAN WE
BUILD WEALTH IN MEXICO BUT GIVE
GIVE A ON ECONOMIC.
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL THE PEOPLE
OF OUR STATE ALL THE PEOPLE OF
MEXICO A IN THAT IN THAT ARE FOR
AND THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT.
WE CAN BRING MORE INVESTMENT. TO
OUR OUR ECONOMIES BY WORKING
TOGETHER AND THERE ARE SO MANY
AREAS THAT YOU'VE.
THAT I'VE HEARD AND SOME OF THE
PRESENTATIONS WERE WE CAN DO
THAT AND AND AND MAKE THAT --
MORE MORE EFFICIENT THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE THANKS FOR
COMMENTS.
WE ALSO WE WANT TO MOVE ON TO
OUR NEXT SPEAKER LISA METAL YOU
COME FORWARD [inaudible]
THE RELEASE.
THANK YOU FOR A COME IN TODAY I
SAW YOU IN THE AUDIENCE THERE
WERE ARE YOU.
I LEASES EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
COMEY THE SEQUEL THE VALUE A
COMMUNITY BASED ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE NONPROFIT.
BEST KNOWN FOR ITS CAMPAIGN TO
COMBAT IN CONTROL HIGH LEVELS OF
CHILDHOOD ASMAN CALIFORNIA'S
IMPERIAL VALLEY AND SURROUNDING
AREAS. FOR THIRTEEN YEARS OF MR
MILL HAS ADVICE LOCAL REGIONAL
STATE PROGRAMS ON ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES AFFECTING RURAL
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA'S
BORDER.
WITH MEXICO.
HE HAS ALSO BEEN INVOLVED IN
LITIGATION AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TO
FORCE GOVERNMENT REGULAR USED
REGULATORS TO MORE EFFECTIVELY
PROTECT.
RESIDENTS FROM AIR POLLUTION AND
FOR THAT WE WE THANK YOU NOT
ENOUGH IS BEING DONE BUT WITH
YOUR ADVOCACY -- WE WE ARE
MAKING PROGRESS THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE.
THEY DINNER READY AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THE SHAPE THE
IMITATION.
I AND I DO HAVE A FEW.
THANKS TO READ HERE BUT I DO
WANT TO ALSO INCLUDED SOMETHING
THAT ARE IN HERE -- BUT
CALIFORNIA MEXICO -- SHOULD BE
VIEWED IN MANAGE AS IT IS ONE
DIVERSE REGION JERRY IN OUR
WORKFORCE AND EXPERTISE FROM
BOTH SIDES OF THE BORDER.
THERE IS NO DIVIDING IN OUR
REGION WHICH HAS HELPED DEVELOP
THE NUMBER ONE ECONOMY IN OUR
NATION OR CONTRIBUTE TO
DEVELOPMENT.
ARE THERE IS A SYMBIOTIC
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN OUR
ECONOMIES OF CALIFORNIAN MEDICAL
CALIFORNIA PROVIDES AN ABUNDANCE
OF RELATIVELY WELL PAYING
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR MEXICO
PROVIDES HUMAN CAPITAL IN
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY -- EQUALLY
BENEFITING BOTH SIDES OF THE
BORDER.
THE RELATIONSHIP ISN'T LIMITED
TO LABOR BOND IT ALSO EXTENDS
THE FINANCIAL CLOUT OF
CALIFORNIA HAS DEVELOPED.
AS ONE OF THE TOP FIVE ECONOMIES
IN THE WORLD.
WITH TRADE BETWEEN CALIFORNIA
MEXICO BI ONE OF THE MAIN
DRIVING FORCES BEHIND THIS.
TRADE ACROSS THE BORDER IS ONE
OF THE MOST FRUITFUL INDUSTRIES
IN THE BORDER.
ESTIMATES THE US ECONOMY PUT A
TRADE ACROSS THE BORDER OVER ONE
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS DAY.
WHICH FROM OUR LOCAL POINT OF
VIEW CAN BE SEEN WITH
AGRICULTURE TRADE.
AND OTHER MANUFACTURING GOODS.
IN OUR REGION WE SEE THE BORDER
TRADE HAPPEN ON A DAILY BASIS
WITH TRANSPORT BY GROUND FREIGHT
INDUSTRY CROSSING.
THE BORDER CONTINUOUSLY
THROUGHOUT THE DAY EVEN OUTSIDE
MAJOR GOODS TRADES.
IF YOU WERE ABOUT TO WALK ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE BORDER YOU
WOULD SEE OUR SPOT INDIVIDUAL
PURCHASING GOODS ON BOTH SIDES
OF THE BORDER.
AND TRANSPORTING THOSE GOODS OF
DOUBLE SIDED BORDER WITH A TOM
FORD WITH SOME VEHICLES.
ARE THE CALIFORNIA ALSO STANCES
AND ECONOMIC LEADER.
BECAUSE OF THE AMOUNTS OF OF
RICH RESOURCES.
AND THE INCREASE IN TRADE ACROSS
THE BORDER BY FACILITATING BY
MULTIPLE TRADE AGREEMENTS.
IF NOT FOR THIS TRADE WE WOULD
BE LESS RICH OF A POSITION THAN
WE ARE TODAY.
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE AT THEBORDER.
THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY TO GROW
BECAUSE WE HAVE A DIVERSE JOB
OPPORTUNITIES AVAILABLE.
BECAUSE OF THE TRADE AND
INNOVATION AND NEW TECHNOLOGIES
WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A TRADE AND
SHIPPING POSITIONS THAT HAVE A
LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY
TO SUPPORT THEIR FAMILIES.
AND GROW WITH THE REGION.
WE HAVE ALSO SEEN INVESTMENT IN
NEW TECHNOLOGIES WHERE BARREN
LANDS HAVE BEEN DEVELOPED TO
SOLAR FARMS IN GREEN ENERGY
INDUSTRIES.
WHY THERE HAVE BEEN?
ALWAYS A DESTRUCTIVE AMONG
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITIES.
WHEN IT COMES TO FINANCIAL
MATTERS IN SOME SECTORS?
THIS IS TRUSTS IT'S NOT ON IS IS
NOT NOT UNKNOWN TO US LIVING AT
THE BORDER.
WALL THE QUESTION AGAINST CROSS
BORDER WORK AND TRADE IS ALWAYS
WHERE TO DOLLARS AND UP.
BUT WHILE THIS MAY BE A NATIONAL
ARGUMENT WE FIRSTHAND SEE THAT
THE DOLLARS ARE SPENT ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE BORDER AND ARE
SPENT IN PROJECTS FOR EXAMPLE
JUST IN THE IN THE RIVER FOR
EXAMPLE THERE WAS.
OVER A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
ABOUT TWENTY OF THOSE MILLION
DOLLARS WERE SPENT.
ON THE MEXICO SIDE AND OTHERS A
CONTRIBUTED FROM CALIFORNIA.
YET IT'S STILL THE REMAINS ABOUT
EIGHTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS JUST
TO SOLVE THAT PROBLEM.
WELL CALIFORNIA AIMS TO CONTINUE
TO GROW AND MAINTAIN AN EVER
INCREASING ECONOMY.
WE SHOULD BE AWARE THAT.
THERE IS A PRICE TO PAY WE
SHOULD NEVER DISREGARD OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITIES.
THIS IS WHY WE BELIEVE THAT
ESTABLISH AN INCREASING PRESENCE
IN OVERSIGHT OVER THE BORDER
REGION IS AN IMPORTANT MECHANISM.
WE ARE AT THE BELIEVE THAT THE
BORDER UNIT A BORDER UNIT FROM
THE STATE TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT
GUIDANCE ENFORCEMENT WILL BE AN
IMPORTANT FACTOR MOVING FORWARD.
WITH OUR BI NATIONAL-RELATIONSHIP.
WHILE NOT ALL WELCOME SUCH AN
INSTITUTION IT MAY WELL PROVIDE
NEW AVENUES TO MAKE CALIFORNIA
MEXICO AN EXAMPLE OF A HEALTHY
AND SOCIALLY CONSCIENCE ECONOMY.
GROWING A BI NATIONAL ECONOMY.
IS ALSO SHARING A BI NATIONAL
RESOURCES AND BI NATIONAL
BURDENS THE NEW RIVER WHICH
TRAVELS NORTH AT A RATE OF TWO
FEET PER SECOND.
IT MAKES THE GALLEY TO CALEXICO
FROM MEXICO TO CALEXICO BRINGING
WASTE WATER INTO THE US
REPRESENTS A MAJOR ENVIRONMENTAL
CONCERN AT THE BORDER.
THOSE OF US WHO LIVE AT THE
BORDER.
YOU KNOW WHEN WE HEAR THE
NATIONAL DISCUSSIONS ABOUT --
WHICH IS A REALITY YOU KNOW
THERE IS A LEGAL AND ILLICIT
TRADE -- BOWL IS HUMAN WHETHER
IT'S DRUGS WE UNDERSTAND THAT'S
A PROBLEM BUT THE NEW RIVER
TRANSPORTS AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
THE ILLEGAL IMPORTATION OF
HAZARDOUS WASTE SEWAGE WASTE
COMING INTO A BORDER YET WE
IGNORED AS THOUGH.
IT'S OKAY TO TURN A BLIND EYE ON
ONE THE ILLEGAL PROBLEM BUT BUT
TURNED -- BUT FOCUS ON ANOTHER
ONE FOR US IT'S A REALITY IT'S
THERE AND IT'S AFFECTING PUBLIC
HEALTH -- THE SOLVENCY ALSO
EXTENDS FROM THE COACHELLA
VALLEY.
WHICH IS ALSO PART OF THE BORDER
REGION INTO THE IMPERIAL VALLEY
AND TO MAKE TO KELLY.
WE SHARE THE AIR BASE IN AND WE
SHARE THE AIR BEING THE LARGEST
LAKE IN CALIFORNIA WHICH IS HAS
HIGHER SALINITY.
THEN THE OCEAN.
AS A LAKE EVAPORATES ELISE
BEHIND DUST CONTAINING HAVE
HAZARDOUS POLLUTANTS SUCH AS
SELENIUM ARSENIC AND TRACES OF
PESTICIDES.
THIS HAS ALSO SERVED AS A SOME
FOR AGRICULTURE AND THE REASON
WHY WE HAVE THIS SIZE AND THE
SETTLEMENT PARTICULATES ARE.
ARE PICKED UP BY THE WINDS AND
CAN BE CARRIED OVER HUNDREDS OF
MILES.
HAVING THESE UNDER RESOURCE
COMMUNITY SUFFER FROM
RESPIRATORY PROBLEMS AND
CARDIOVASCULAR.
DISEASES.
AS WE FACE A BORDER
ENVIRONMENTAL CRISIS WITH THE
LOOMING SONG SEE DEVASTATION.
AND CROSS BORDER POLLUTION THE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITY SHOULD BE THE
UTMOST PRIORITY.
STUDENTS THAT LIVE IN THE
CALIFORNIA MEXICO BORDER REGION
ARE SUFFERING FROM AN ILLNESS
SUCH AS ASTHMA AND OTHER
RESPIRATORY CONDITIONS THAT
REQUIRE A CONSTANT AND
MINISTRATION A MEDICATION.
DURING SCHOOL HOURS AND LIMITED
NOT AN A. B. LIMITED IF NOT
DENIED BY. TO ADMINISTER ANY
MEDICATION GIVEN.
BY OUT OF STATE HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS.
WHAT I MEAN BY THAT IS THAT
THERE ARE HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
LICENSE BY CALIFORNIA?
THAT ARE DOING BUSINESS IN THESE
HYBRID TYPE OF PLANS YET.
WHENEVER THEY BRING THE
MEDICATION INTO.
THE SCHOOLS THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED
TO ADMINISTER THAT AND THAT DOES
NOT MAKE ANY SENSE AND THAT IS
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY CALL ME
THEY SEE BECAUSE I IT.
IS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN
FORTY THREE WHICH WILL PROMOTING
HEALTH EQUITY FOR CHILDREN IN
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND REQUIRES A
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO ACCEPT A
WRITTEN STATEMENT FROM A
PHYSICIAN OR SURGEON WHO IS.
CONTRACTED WITH BI NATIONAL
HEALTH PLAN WHICH IS LICENSE IN
CALIFORNIA FOR THE PURPOSES OF
AUTHORIZING STUDENTS.
OR PEOPLE'S TO BE ASSISTED BY
SCHOOL NURSE OR OTHER DESIGNATED
SCHOOL PERSONNEL AND TO BE ABLE
TO CARRY A SEVEN MINISTER AND
HELD ASTHMA MEDICATION MANY THIS
KIDS CARRY THEIR ASTHMA
MEDICATION AS A WAS CONTRABAND.
AND YOU KNOW WHEN I HEARD THAT
IT WAS THE UNITED STATES THIS
MORNING.
IT IS NECESSARY FOR OUR REGION
TO ENSURE AN INCREASE OF AYE
NATIONAL FORSMAN OF REGULATIONS
TO ADDRESS THESE ENVIRONMENTAL
AND SOCIAL CONCERNS.
ASKED PRACTICES OF BOTH SIDES OF
THE BORDER.
AND THAT AFFECT OUR COMMUNITY
AND JUST AS OUR BI NATIONAL
ECONOMY THERE IS NO DIVIDING
LINE POLLUTION KNOWS NO BORDER.
AN IMPACT IN THE REGION AS A
WHOLE THE STATE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE SUPPORT AND GUIDANCE.
FROM ITS PREVIOUS EXPERIENCE
DEALING WITH SIMILAR ISSUES IN
MAY HE GO. ONE ONE SUCH ISSUE.
IS -- IN THE TO FOLLOW THROUGH
IN THE PLANNING OF IMPLEMENTING
SOLUTIONS A LONG TERM PLANNING.
THERE IS A MOVEMENT IN MAKES YOU
KELLY THAT WE HAVE BEEN DOING
WORK FOR THE LAST TWENTY YEARS
IN THE BORDER REGION.
pTWO THOUSANDS WE DID A SURVEY
OUT THERE IN MAY HE KILEY WAS
MORE CONCERNED ABOUT
CONSERVATION.
BUT AS THEIR RESOURCES HAVE
RECENTLY BEEN THREATENING WE
HAVE SEEN A MOVEMENT A SEARCH OF
CITIZEN MOVEMENT THAT WANT TO DO
LONG RANGE PLANNING.
THEY ARE THE ONE I WANT TO JUST
BE SUBJECT TO POLITICAL TERMS
THEY DON'T WANT TO HIT THE RESET
BUTTON EVERY TIME ADJOURNMENTS
THEY WANT TO BE ABLE TO DO LONG
TERM PLANNING AND THAT IS MADE
UP OF ACADEMIA.
A PROFESSIONALS OF COMMUNITY --
BUSINESS -- AND SO EVEN RECENTLY
THE TWO UNIVERSITIES DOWN THERE
IS -- THE DECK AND AND WHILE THE
SAVER EITHER SIGN IN PAYMENTS
WITH US WE KNOW THEY'RE EAGER TO
BE PART OF THE DISCUSSION THERE
EAGER. TO BE CONVENERS NEUTRAL
COMMUTERS TO BRING BOTH SIDES OF
THE BORDER TOGETHER --
CALIFORNIA SHOULD ALSO SEEK TO
SUPPORT MAY GOING PROVIDING
TRAINING AND OPPORTUNITIES TO
ADDRESS ALL THE PREVIOUS ISSUES
MENTION AND IN THIS TESTIMONY.
WE ARE AT THE CROSSROADS FOR
HELPING OUR SISTER COMMUNITIES
TO THE SOUTH WILL LEAD LONG TERM
BENEFITS FOR ALL OF US --
FINALLY -- THE STATE GOVERNMENT
NEEDS TO CREATE MORE OFFICES TO
MOVE THOSE EXISTING.
AND MOVE THOSE EXISTING OFFICES
TO THE BORDER BY WAY STRATEGIC
LOCATION AND ESTABLISHING ACTIVE
PERFORMANCE MEASURES -- SO.
THIS IS A I HAVE BEEN A MEMBER
OF THE FEDERAL ADVISORY OARD
THE GOOD NEIGHBOR ENVIRONMENTAL
BOARD I'M VERY FAMILIAR.
WITH A LOT OF THIS PLANNING AND
AND AND A LOT OF THE
RECOMMENDATION I BE PUT NOT ONLY
BY MYSELF BUT BUT MANY EXPERTS --
THROUGHOUT THE YEARS AND AND YOU
KNOW YOU CAN LOOK AT THOSE YOU
CAN LOOK UP OR TWENTY TWENTY OR
TWENTY TWELVE THE BI NATIONAL
TASK FORCES I HAVE BEEN PART OF
THAT FOR THE LAST TWENTY YEARS.
AND IT SEEMS LIKE EVERY TIME
GOVERNMENT IS GIVING AND I'M
TALKING ABOUT CALIFORNIA.
EVERY TIME CALIFORNIA'S GIVEN
DIRECTION TO PUT A PLAN TOGETHER
IT'S ALWAYS SORT OF A COPY PASTE
I REVISITED THE SAME THING I
THINK MEXICO AND HOW CALIFORNIA.
IS IS IN A A YOU KNOW THEIR IN A
DIFFERENT POSITION THAT THEY
MIGHT HAVE BEEN BEFORE I THINK
THERE'S A LOT MORE MOMENTUM
THERE'S A LOT OF PROFESSIONALS.
IN AREAS LIKE THE BORDER IT IN I
CAN SAY MORE PROBABLY MORE
DEFINITELY THE FINE AND IMPERIAL
MEXICALI AND I'M PRETTY SURE
THIS.
AND SAN DIEGO A LOT OF WE DROP A
LOT OF PROFESSIONS MONEY GUY
BECAUSE THEY HAVE PUT THE EFFORT
IN AN EMPHASIS ON CREATING A AN
EDUCATED POPULATION.
SO WE HAVE TO WORK TOGETHER TO
BE ABLE TO CREATE SOLUTIONS
TOGETHER THERE ARE RESOURCES IN
CALIFORNIA THERE'S EXPERTS IN
MAY HE KILEY AND I THINK THAT
THE NEW ADMINISTRATION RIGHT NOW
ON BOTH SIDES WHETHER IT'S
CALIFORNIA.
OR OR MAY HE GO A REALLY
CONDUCIVE TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
I WOULD HOPE THAT THROUGH THIS
HEARING THAT THERE IS A A PLAN.
I AND IN IN A PATHWAY TO BE ABLE
TO MODERNIZE THE WAY WE DO
BUSINESS -- INTO MY THAT POINTS
REAL QUICK IS THAT THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD TO TAKE A LEAD
AND THEY ACTUALLY THE BOARD --
APPROVED THE CREATION OF A
BORDER PROGRAM -- AND AND THAT
WAS AS A RESULT OF BECAUSE THEY
HAD PREVIOUSLY HAD -- DEPLOYED
SOME OF THEIR STAFF THEY DID
BUSINESS AS USUAL THEY LISTEN TO
US AND THEN THEY SAID YEAH WE
AGREE WE GOT TO DO THINGS
DIFFERENTLY THERE'S A NEW
ADMINISTRATION NOW.
THEY WANT TO AND FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND THEY THEY WANT TO
BRING AN ENTIRE MORE
COMPREHENSIVE MOTOR PROGRAM SO
WE HOPE THAT THIS IS A TREND
THAT WE CONTINUE TO TAKE
OPPORTUNITY AND AND BE ABLE --
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
ENTHUSIASM TO THE BANK KILEY
I'VE LIVED IN THE BORDER I HAVE
WORKED ON BORDER ISSUES FOR
TWENTY YEARS AND THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME I SEE THIS MONO
MOMENTUM AND I WANT TO THANK.
THE CENTER FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP I
ALSO WANT TO THANK.
THE MEMBER TODD GLORIA.
SO MEMBER THAT'LL GARCIA -- I
WANT -- TO THANGKA -- SENATOR --
OF CINNAMON WESSEL -- SPEAKER
AND ON ALL OF YOU HAVE DONE A
TREMENDOUS JOB AND HAVING THESE
CONVERSATIONS FOR MEDICAL WE AS
A COMMUNITY ORGANIZATION.
ARE ABLE TO TO JUMP ON BOARD
THAT ENTHUSIASM AND THAT-LEADERSHIP SO I THANK YOU FOR
THAT -- ALSO AB SIX ONE SEVEN
ONE LAST THING IS -- IS A REALLY
GOOD STRATEGY IMPERIAL AND MANY
KILEY HAPPENS IN HERE HAS HE WAS
SELECTED FOR AB SIX ONE SEVEN
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS PROGRAM --
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME SUCH A
PROGRAM AND WE HAVE BEEN
COMMUNICATING THAT TO OUR
MEXICAN.
MAY HE KILEY OF PARTNERS BUT I
THINK IT WOULD BE A GOOD PROGRAM
TO IMPLEMENT ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE BORDER.
SO WITH THAT I THANK YOU FOR FOR
OF BODY ME HERE AND I APPRECIATE --
YOUR ATTENTION TO THIS THANK YOU
AND AND I WANNA I WANNA JUST
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND
AND I KNOW WE HAD A MEDIAN --
WITH A LOT OF THE WORK SHE HAD
DONE AND IMPERIAL -- WHERE WE
TALKED ABOUT HEALTH ISSUES WE
HAD HEALTH ISSUES FORUM AND I
KNOW YOU WERE THERE?
A BILL CAME OUT OF THAT I WORKED
ON A BILL -- LAST YEAR TO GET
THE OFFICE OF BI NATIONAL HEALTH
TO WORK ON OF IDENTIFIED SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES WITH -- PROVIDING --
SOLUTIONS TO SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS AT THE BORDER THAT ARE
ONLY REALLY LARGELY PROBLEMS AT
THE BORDER.
AND I KNOW THEY WERE ESTABLISHED
FOR THAT PURPOSE AND I YOU KNOW
WE HAVE TO REALLY REVIEW VISIT
THIS BECAUSE EXIST OR FUNDED.
AND I FOR ONE AM NOT A BIG --
FAN OF OF OF THEIR WORK AND I
THINK THEY CAN DO A BETTER JOB
AND AND WE NEED TO SIT DOWN WITH
THEM AND WE NEED TO WORK
TOGETHER TO SEE HOW WE CAN
ACTIVATE THEM.
AND GET THEM -- TO PERFORM
ACCORDING TO WHAT.
THE STATUTE OF OF OF THAT THAT
BECAUSE THEY'RE FOR CREATION
FIRST PLACE.
WE HAVE TO WE HAVE TO EVALUATE
THE PERFORMANCE AND I DON'T
THINK THAT'S BEEN DONE
ADEQUATELY AND MAYBE UNDER THIS
IN A NEW ADMINISTRATION.
THERE'S HOPE THAT THAT
SPECIFICALLY THE SPECIFIC
DIVISION WILL WILL WILL BE
REVIEWED AND I LIKE TO WORK WITH
YOU ON BECAUSE IN HER THANK YOU
FOR COMING.
OUR FINAL SPEAKER IS DOCTOR
BLAST BUT IS SYNDICATE AS HE
FOUNDED AND SERVES AS DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA GLOBAL ENERGY
WATER.
AND INFRASTRUCTURE INNOVATION
INITIATIVE A STANDARD AT
STANFORD UNIVERSITY.
SPONSORED BY THE BILL LANE
CENTER FOR AMERICAN WEST.
AND THE PRE COURT INSTITUTE FOR
ENERGY.
AT THE PRECOURT INSTITUTE BLAST
BUT ISN'T BECAUSE RUNS THE
MEXICO.
CLEAN ECONOMY TWENTY FIFTY
PROJECT WHICH WAS FUNDED BY.
USA IT IS A GLOBAL DEVELOPMENT
ALLIANCE WELCOME THANKS FOR
BEING HERE [inaudible]
AND PLEASE.
IN THE RING WITH SO MUCH
CONVENIENCE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INVITATION AN
OPPORTUNITY 2% SOME ADDITIONAL
CONSIDERATIONS TO WHAT HAS BEEN
ALREADY PERCENT IT.
BEING PRESENTED TO THE TO THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON CALIFORNIA
MEXICO CORPORATION ABOUT THE
GROWING BI NATIONAL ECONOMY ON
THESE THE TENTH ANNIVERSARY OF
THE CALIFORNIA MEXICO ADVOCACY
DAY.
IT IS MY PLEASURE TO INFORM.
THIS COMMITTEE THAT AT STANFORD
UNIVERSITY WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
HARD. TO STRENGTHEN OUR
INTERACTION WITH MEXICO BEYOND
OUR EXISTENCE STUDENT
RECRUITMENT RESEARCH AND
TEACHING PROGRAMS.
WITH THE SUPPORT OF THE STEP OF
STANFORD UNIVERSITY SPEAKER
INCENTIVE FOR ENERGY AND THE
BILLING CENTER FOR THE AMERICAN
WEST WHICH INCLUDES MEXICO AND
CANADA AS PART OF ITS SCOPE OF
RESEARCH AND ACTIVITIES.
WE ARE ESTABLISHING A
COLLABORATIVE POLICY EXCHANGE
PROGRAM WITH GOVERNMENT BUSINESS
NONPROFIT ACT AND ACADEMIC
INSTITUTIONS IN MEXICO.
THE PROGRAM TAKES THE NEXUS
[inaudible]
PERSPECTIVE.
I SURE WITH THE SYSTEMS APPROACH
TO INNOVATION IN ENERGY WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE BASED ON
CALIFORNIA'S EXPERIENCE
IMPLEMENTING A CLEAN ECONOMY
MODEL SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND SIX AS A PILOT FOR
THIS PROGRAM WITH VALLEY'S A
UNIVERSITY INDUSTRY GOVERNMENT
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE SUPPORT OF
THE USA AT AGENCY UNIT US AGENCY
FOR INTERNATIONAL DEVELOPMENT
USA ID.
THE STAFF FOR USA THE MEXICO
CLEAN ECONOMY TWENTY FIFTY
GLOBAL DEVELOPMENT ALLIANCE MC
TWENTY FIFTY AIMS TO MAXIMIZE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LOW CARBON
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT THROUGH THE
COMPENSATION AND ENERGY
TRANSITION IN MEXICO IN OUR
REGION.
I WANT TO HIGHLAND HIGHLIGHT
THAT THIS IS CURRENTLY THE ONLY
PROGRAM SUPPORTING CLEAN ENERGY
AND SUSTAINABLE DEVELOPMENT
ACTIVITIES IN MEXICO FUNDED BY.
USA ID.
THE SEWER THE USA ID SUPPORT
CONTEST MATCHING FUNDS TO WHAT
STAFF WERE WAS ABLE TO RAISE
THROUGH GENEROUS CONTRIBUTIONS
FOR INDIVIDUALS IN COURT AND
CORPORATIONS INTERESTED IN
SUPPORTING THE LAUNCH AND
ACTIVISTS OF THE PROGRAM.
IS OUR GOAL TO INSTITUTIONALIZE
THIS PROGRAM AT STANFORD BEYOND
TWENTY TWENTY WITH THE SUPPORT
OF OUR GROWING NUMBER OF
INDUSTRIAL INDIVIDUAL AND STATE
AGENCY PARTNERS.
MC TWENTY FIFTY AIMS TO SUPPORT
MEXICO'S EFFORT TO BRIDGE THE
GAP BETWEEN THEONGOING
TRANSFORMATION OF THE ENERGY
SECTOR IN MEXICO AND REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GASES.
GAS EMISSIONS MEXICO NEEDS TO
LINK THE TRANSFORMATION OF ITS
ENERGY.
THE SYSTEM TO GREENHOUSE THE
CALL PLEADING TO BE SUCCESSFUL
IN ACHIEVING THE EMISSION
REDUCTIONS UNDER THE PARIS
AGREEMENT.
AS THE NEW FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION IN MEXICO
SHIFTING THE MEXICAN ENERGY PART
DIED.
TOWARDS SELF SUFFICIENCY EQUITY
AND SUSTAINABILITY.
THERE IS A WINDOW OF OPPORTUNITY
TO ADVANCE THE CRBONIZATION
TECHNOLOGICAL AND POLICY PATH.
SUCH AS RENEWABLE ENERGY ENERGY
EFFICIENCY MARK URBAN AND
TRANSFER INTO DEVELOPMENT AS
WELL AS TO SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF ITS CARBON
PRICING POLICY I NEED TO MERGING
EMISSIONS TRADING SYSTEM.
MAKES THE MEXICO ETS.
NC E. TWENTY FIFTY FOCUS ON HOW
TO LEVERAGE MEXICO'S CURRENT
TRANSFORMATION MODERNIZATION OF
THE ENERGY SECTOR AND CLIMATE
ACTION AMBITION.
THAT'S POLICY DRIVERS THE
TRIGGER BUSINESSTRANSFORMATION
AND LOW CARBON INNOVATION
PROCESS IN SUPPORT OF A CLEAN
INCLUSIVE AND PROSPEROUS
REGIONAL ECONOMY. ONE SET OF
THESE PROJECTS BUSINESS
COLLABORATORS AND SUPPORTING
ORGANIZATION IS CONTRIBUTING TO
A LOW CARBON ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WHO LOW CARBON
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT EFFORTS IN
MEXICO BY INTEGRATING REGIONAL
CLEAN TECH MARKETS.
THE OTHER SET OF COLLABORATIVE
COLLABORATORS WILL STRENGTHEN
THE LEGISLATIVE AND POLICY
FORMULATION PROCESS.
IN MEXICO BY PROVIDING
INTERDISCIPLINARY MARKET BASED
SOLUTIONS TO CAUGHT GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS EFFICIENTLY.
WHILE WE ARE DEVELOPING A
RESEARCH AND TEACHING DIGIT
AGENDA AROUND THIS PROGRAM
ACTIVITIES OUR ALLIANCE ALSO
SUPPORTS SUPPORTS BUSINESS TO
BUSINESS DIALOGUE SOME DECISIONS
TO ALIGN POSITION SOME
PERSPECTIVES INTERNALLY AMONG
INDUSTRIAL SECTORS.
WHAT ALSO FACILITATING A POLICY
CONSTRUCTIVE DIALOGUE?
WITH GOVERNMENT.
ULTIMATELY WE AIM TO INFORM THE
POLICY PROCESS IN MEXICO.
AND IF I ALWAYS STAYED IN MY
PUBLIC PRESENTATIONS INTERESTED
AT TO INTERESTED GROUPS BOTH IN
MEXICO IN CALIFORNIA.
I SAY AS A MEXICAN WORKING AT
STANFORD I WANT TO BRING SILICON
VALLEY AND SACRAMENTO CLOSE TO
MEXICO.
MEXICO IS IS HIGHLY PRESENT IN
IN CITIES LIKE SAN DIEGO AND LOS
ANGELES.
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA NOT YET
SO MUCH.
THE PROGRAM HAS TO IMPACT AREAS
SMALLER COMMUNITIES.
OF LOW CARBON ENERGY
TRANSFORMATION AYE NEEDS FOR ITS
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE INNOVATION.
THE GOAL OF THE SUB THEME IS TO
SERVE SPREE SPEAR HAD A
CONVERSATION IN MEXICO AROUND
THE POTENTIAL FOR TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCE A LOW CARBON ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT.
IN KEY AREAS.
THE KEY URBAN AREAS ON ISSUES
SUCH AS TRANSPORT ENERGY AND
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE CONVERSATION WILL FOCUS ON
TRANSITIONING URBAN AREAS ON THE
MEXICAN SIDE OF THE BORDER THE
GREATER ENERGY RESOURCE
EFFICIENCY.
AND THE CARBON STATION WHILE
ALSO TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
BUSINESS OPPORTUNITIES TO
SUPPORT SMART CLEAN GROWTH IN
NORTH AMERICA.
M. C. E. TWENTY FIFTY WILL FOCUS
ON THE PARTY STORE. FOR ENHANCE
COLLABORATION WITH CALIFORNIA
AND THE TO EMERGING INNOVATION
HOPS.
THE THE I NATIONAL CALLIE BY
HER REGION.
AND MONTEREY NOBODY ON THE
INDUSTRIAL HALL OF MEXICO.
WE'RE CONDUCTING A RESEARCH AND
PLANNING WORKSHOP IN MEXICALI
BAJA CALIFORNIA NEXT MONTH.
WITH THE AIM TO CONDUCT A MAJOR
FORUM ON THESE ISSUES IN MID
NOVEMBER.
IN BAJA WHERE WE HOPE A STRIP A
STRONG REPRESENTATION FROM THE
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT AND
BUSINESS COMMUNITY AS WELL AS
FROM THE MEXICAN FEDERAL AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
WILL BE IN ATTENDANCE.
I HOPE YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS COULD BE PART OF THESE
M. C. E. TWENTY FIFTY CALIBER
HOT FORUM WHICH IS BEING
DEVEOPED WITH LOCAL REGIONAL
PARTNERS.
PERHAPS SOME OF YOU CAN ALSO
JOIN US FOR THE PLANNING AND
RESEARCH WORK TRUCK AS WE ASSESS
THE STATE OF A FIRST IN
CALABASAS CHALLENGES AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LOW CARBON
DEVELOPMENT IN THE REGION.
SOMETIMES WITH THE HEADLINES
ABOUT THE U. S MEXICO BORDER IN
THE NEWS WE TEND TO FORGET THAT
THIS REGION REPRESENTS THE
FOURTH LARGEST ECONOMY OF THE
WORLD.
PAINTER CONNECTIVITY THAT WE
HAVE DEVELOPED IN THAT CALLIE BY
OUR REGION SHOULD REPRESENT THE
FUTURE OF THE BORDER.
NOT THE EXCEPTION [inaudible]
AND MONTEREY.
NOT THE EXCEPTION PERHAPS WITH
THE SUPPORT OF CALIFORNIA BOTH.
THE CALIPARI CHEN AND MONTEREY
NOBODY ON CAN GENERATE A
TRANSFORMATIVE PROCESS IN THE
NORTH OF MEXICO.
TOWARDS A REGIONAL CLEAN ECONOMY.
ON CARBON PRICING [inaudible]
THIS SUPERTEAM.
WE AIM TO SUPPORT THAT THE THAT
DAY EMERGING EMISSIONS --
TRADING SYSTEM IN MEXICO IN
ORDER TO ACHIEVE IT --
GREENHOUSE GAS MITIGATION GOLD
UNDER THESE THEME WE HAVE
ALREADY MADE SOME -- PROGRESS IN
BUILDING CALIFORNIA MEXICO
PARTNERSHIPS IN APRIL OF LAST
YEAR WE HOSTED A HIGH LEVEL
DIALOGUE ON CARBON MARKETS IN
MEXICO WITH THE PRIVATE SECTOR
AND SENIOR OFFICIALS FROM THE
MINISTRY OF ENVIRONMENT NATURAL
RESOURCES.
THE THE MINISTRY OF ENERGY THE
MINISTRY OF ECONOMY AND ATTORNEY
GENERAL FOR THE ENVIRONMENT --
OFFICE I THESE DIALOGUES SEEING
SENIOR OFFICIAL EXPLAINED THE
IMPORTANCE OF MEXICO'S INDUSTRY.
COMPLYING WITH THE NATIONAL
DETERMINE CONTRIBUTIONS UNDER
THE PARIS AGREEMENT THROUGH THE
NEW EMISSIONS TRADING SYSTEM.
AND SEAT TWENTY FIFTY BROUGHT
DOWN RICHARD CORY EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD TO SHARE
CALIFORNIA'S EXPERIENCE IN
DEVELOPING THIS GAP OF TRADE IS
CAP AND TRADE SYSTEM AT THIS
EVENT.
MORE THAN NINETY INDUSTRY WERE
PARTICIPANTS ANOTHER PRIVATE
SECTOR ENTITIES LIKE THE MEXICAN
STOCK EXCHANGE WERE IN
ATTENDANCE.
ALSO LAST YEAR AND SEE TWENTY
FIFTY SPONSORED THE
PARTICIPATION OF TWO MEXICAN
OFFICIALS ONE FROM SOMEONE AT
THE MINISTRY OF ENVIRONMENT AND
NATURAL RESOURCES AND ANOTHER
FROM THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
OF FOR THE ENVIRONMENT IN A
GREENHOUSE GAS -- MONITORING AND
VERIFICATION TRAINING WORKSHOP
ALSO CONDUCTED BY -- A. R. B..
MORE RECENTLY ON NOVEMBER FIFTH
WE CONDUCTED A MULTI STAKEHOLDER
WORK WORKSHOP TO DISCUSS NATURAL
CLIMATE SOLUTIONS AND A CAR ON
MARKETING MEXICO.
OVER HUNDRED REPRESENTATIVES
FROM MEXICAN GOVERNMENT
INSTITUTIONS THE PRIVATE SECTOR
NONPROFIT AND ACADEMIC
INSTITUTIONS DISCUSS THE
CHALLENGES AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR
SCALING UP NATURAL CLIMATE
SOLUTIONS IN MEXICO TO MEET IS
IT AND THE SEAS.
I'M PROVIDE CARBON OFFSETS FOR
THE INTERNATIONAL MARKET.
OUT OF THESE WORKSHOPS B. P.
DECIDED TO JOHN A JOINT EMCEED
TWENTY FIFTY AT THE MAJOR DONOR
[inaudible]
I SORRY THE SELLER.
I'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN THIS
RESEARCH FOR MANY YEARS AND MC A
THE NC NCS -- POLLUTION.
AS WE SPEAK.
THESE BRAVE GLOBAL ENERGY
COMPANY IS FINALIZED
NEGOTIATIONS TO CO INVEST WITH
U. S. ID THROUGH ITS SUSTAINABLE
LANDSCAPES PROGRAM IN IN NATURAL
CLIMATE SOLUTIONS FOR A FORCED
REAP A PILOT PROGRAM IN MEXICO.
JUST LAST WEEK AS WE CONDUCTED A
MEETING WITH ALL THE INDEPENDENT
GREENHOUSE GAS WERE VERY FIRES.
WE CONDUCTED A MEETING WITH ALL
THE INDEPENDENT GREENHOUSE GOT
THEIR FIRES RAGE REGISTERED IN
MEXICO TO DEVELOP A WORK PLAN TO
STRENGTHEN THE TRANSPARENCY OF
MEXICO'S NATIONAL RAGE IT
GREENHOUSE REGISTRY KNOWN AS
RAINY FOR THE SPANISH.
ACRONYM AS WELL AS THE
MEASUREMENT -- REPORTING I'M
VERIFICATION MRB ASPECTS OF THE
MEXICO ETS UNIX ITS PILOT PHASE
TO BE LAUNCHED LATER THIS YEAR.
A CREDIBLE CARBON MARKET IN
MEXICO WILL ATTRACT IMPORTANT
CLIMATE FINANCE RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT THE CARBONIZATION AND
CLEAN INNOVATION.
WE WILL CONTINUE WITH A SERIES
OF DIALOGUES THAT WITH POLICY
MAKERS THE PRIVATE SECTOR AND
KEY STAKEHOLDERS IN MEXICO WHICH
WILL BE INFORMED BY LESSONS
LEARNED FROM CALIFORNIA AND
OTHER INITIATIVES IN NORTH
AMERICAN AND ARE AROUND THE
WORLD.
NC TWENTY FIFTY WILL DEVELOP NEW
OPPORTUNITIES TO FOR OUR FACULTY
RESEARCH ISN'T AND STUDENTS TO
ENGAGE OUR PROGRAM.
WE WILL DEVELOP A CALIFORNIA
MEXICO RESEARCH AGENDA POLICY
REPORTS FOR THIS THE THIS
DECISION MAKERS MORE TECHNICAL
ANALYSIS FOR STRATEGIC PLANNING
AND CAPACITY BUILDING WORKSHOPS
IN ORDER TO TRICK FLOOR
IMPLEMENTATION PATH. FOR
EFFECTIVE THE CARBONIZATION
SOLUTIONS IN OUR REGION.
WHAT IS THE THING THE ONLY FROM
THE NEW FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
LEADERSHIP I MEXICO?
LAST WEEK PRESIDENT LOPEZ
OBRADOR PRESENTED THAT HE'S
NATIONAL DEVELOPMENT PLAN
201-924-2420 FOUR THE PLAN
ESTABLISHES THREE CROSS CROSS
CUTTING POLICY GUIDELINES TO HIS
NATIONAL PROJECT.
GENDER EQUALITY NO
DISCRIMINATION AND INCLUSION
FIGHT AGAINST CORRUPTION
CORRUPTION AND PUBLIC ADMIN
ADMINISTRATION IMPROVEMENT ADD.
THREE TERRITORY AND SUSTAINABLE
DEVELOPMENT M. C. E. TWENTY
FIFTY ALIGNS WELL WITH ALL OF
ALL THREE OF THESE NEW PRIORITY
IN MEXICO.
FIRST WE'RE BUILDING CAPACITY
TRAINING PROGRAMS INTO OUR WORK
ON MOBILE ELECT FROM ABILITY
NOVATION TO ENSURE THAT.
THE RESULTING LOW CARBON JOBS
ARE ACCESSIBLE TO ALL TO ALL.
AN HOUR.
NATURAL CLIMATE SOLUTIONS WORK
TARGETS BENEFITS TO THE MOST
MARGINALIZED RURAL AGRICULTURAL
AND FOREST COMMUNITIES TO ENABLE
INCREASE FORREST GUMP
CONSERVATION.
PARTICULARLY IN THE SOUTH OF
MEXICO DESIGNING AND
IMPLEMENTING OF A TRANSPARENT
STANDARDIZED AN INDEPENDENT
MONEY TOWARD ETS IN MEXICO BOTH
BENEFIT.
BOTH BENEFITS BENEFITS FROM AND
HELPS BUILD OPEN GOVERNMENT.
THE THIRD PRIORITY IS DIRECTLY
ALONG WITH MC TWENTY FIFTY AIMS
TO AN AIMS -- TO AND THE GOLD.
WE WANT TO SUPPORT SMART CLEAN
SAFE AND INCLUSIVE COMMUNITIES
IN OUR REGION SOCIAL JUSTICE IS
A KEY PRINCIPLE IN ALL ASPECTS
OF THE NEW.
NATIONAL DEVELOPMENT PLAN AND
HERE'S AN EXAMPLE PERTINENT TO
THE CLEAN ENERGY SECTOR AND I
QUOTE.
THE NEW ENERGY POLICY OF THE
MEXICAN STATE WILL BE TO PROMOTE
SUSTAINABLE DEVELOPMENT THROUGH
THE INCORPORATION OF POPULATION.
I COMMUNITIES IN ENERGY
PRODUCTION FROM RENEWABLE
SOURCES WHICH IN TURN WILL
FUNDAMENTALLY WILL BE
FUNDAMENTAL TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE ELECTRICITY TO THE SMALL
AND REMOTE COMMUNITIES THE STILL
DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO EAT AND
THAT AMOUNT TO APPROXIMATELY.
TWO MILLION INHABITANTS THE
ENERGY TRANSITION WILL SERVE AS
A BASIS FOR TWO FULL FOSTER THE
EMERGENCE OF SOCIAL OF THE
SOCIAL SECTOR IN THIS AREA.
AS WELL AS TWO FOR MEN THEY YOU
R INDUSTRIALIZATION OF THE
COUNTRY END OF QUOTE.
I BELIEVE CALIFORNIA.
I NEEDS DYNAMIC ECONOMY.
WITH ITS INNOVATIVE CLEAN TECH
INDUSTRY AS WELL AS THE WEALTH
OF STATE POLLS YOU KNOW HOW ON
CLIMATE ACTION AND INVESTMENT TO
SPUR LOW CARBON DEVELOPMENT CAN
ASSIST THE PARTNER.
CAN ASSIST AND PARTNER WITH
MEXICO IN ITS EFFORT TO BE A
MORE COST INCLUSIVE AND
SUSTAINABLE SOCIETY FOR THE
BENEFIT OF OUR REGIONAL ECONOMY.
A PROSPEROUS CLEAN.
FAITH AND INCLUSIVE MEXICO
WILLING HOUSE ENHANCE OUR
REGIONAL COMPETITIVENESS LINKING
OUR CLEAN TECH VALUE CHAIN SEEN
CHANGE.
THINGS IN THE SEARCH OF THAN A
NEXT GENERATION ENERGY SYSTEMS
OR DEVELOP BEING ELECTRUM
ABILITIES THE SOLUTIONS FOR
PUBLIC TRANSPORT AND LOGISTICS
FOR INSTANCE.
CAN ONLY MAKE THIS EMERGING
ISSUES INDUSTRY STRONGER. FOR
NOW. FOR DECADES NOW MEXICO HAS
BEEN ABLE TO INTEGRATE POWERFUL
MANUFACTURING DESIGN AND
INNOVATION KLOSTERS TO SUPPLY
THE CONVENTIONAL AUTO INDUSTRY
BECOMING.
LAST YEAR THE FOURTH LARGEST
LARGEST EXPORTER IN THE SECTOR.
MOREOVER THIS SEEMS TO BE THE
TREND IN THE AEROSPACE INDUSTRY
GIVING.
MAJOR FOREIGN INVESTMENT IN THE
SECTOR.
IN THE MEXICAN IN THE CENTER OF
MEXICO IN THE LAST FEW DECADES.
IN.
TWENTY FIFTEEN WE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTNER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION TO
CONDUCT A FULL OP TRIP TO
GOVERNOR BROWN'S TWENTY FOURTEEN
VISIT TO MEXICO.
ARE CALIFORNIA -- CALIFORNIA
CLEAN TECHNICIAN WITH THE
SUPPORT OF GO BASED ON THE
GOVERNMENT OF MEXICO CONNECTED
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS ANOTHER KEY
STAKEHOLDERS LIKE THE FINEST
COMMUNITY AND RESEARCH
INSTITUTIONS WITH BUSINESS
GROUPS FROM BOTH MEXICO IN
CALIFORNIA TO EXPLORE.
TRADE INVESTMENT AND RESEARCH
DEVELOPMENT AND DEMONSTRATION
OPPORTUNITIES.
WE VISITED MEXICO I MONTEREY
NORMALLY ON AND SINCE THEN STAFF
OR HAS BEEN DEVELOPING
INDUSTRIAL ALLIANCE
OPPORTUNITIES WITH BUSINESS
GROUPS IN MEXICO BEHIND MONTEREY
TO VANCE CLEAN INNOVATION AND
CLIMATE.
POLICY RESEARCH IN OUR REGION.
THERE ARE.
IMPORTANT ENERGY AND ENVIRONMENT
CHALLENGES IN OUR BORDER WITH
BAJA.
AND FOR THE ENTIRE USE BOARD OF
MEXICO BORDER REGION.
THAT NEEDS A DEEP UNDERSTANDING
UNTRUE REGIONAL COOPERATION TO
BE RESOLVED.
JUST A MONTH AGO SPEAKER AND
DAWN.
OF THIS STATE OF ASSEMBLY
INVITED ME TO MODERATE A PANEL
ON THE TIJUANA RIVER BASING
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES AS PART OF
HIS INAUGURAL MULTI STAKEHOLDER
CALIFORNIA MEXICO STRATEGIC
DIALOGUE.
THIS ISSUE HAS BEEN THERE FOR
DECADES.
WAITING TO BE RESOLVED.
IT IS TIME TO TAKE ACTION ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE BORDER.
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER.
ONLY AFTER WE FOR SYSTEMS
APPROACH.
AN ORIGINAL PERSPECTIVE TO
ADDRESS COMMON CHALLENGES AND
AND AND ADVANCE HOLISTIC
INTEGRATED SOLUTIONS THERE IS A
WILL WILL ADDRESS DECISIONS
THERE IS AN ASYMMETRY OF
FINANCIAL RESOURCES AND
TECHNICAL CAPACITY BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA AND THE BORDER STATES
AND MAKE AND THE MEXICAN
GOVERNMENT.
WITH THE RETREAT OF THE U. S.
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SUPPORTING
CLEAN ENERGY PROGRAMS AND THE
SHIFTING PRIORITIES DOING HINES
ENERGY SELF SUFFICIENCY IN
MEXICO.
I BELIEVE THIS IS THE TIME
CALIFORNIA SHOULD PRIORITIZE.
COOPERATE COOPERATION WITH
MEXICO. FOR INSTANCE BOTH
GERMANY AND THE UNITED KINGDOM
ARE DOING SO ALL.
SO ALREADY WITH MAJOR
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS IN ALL OF
THESE AREAS NOW IN PLACE IN
MEXICO.
FINALLY.
WE ARE DEVELOPING A STRATEGIC
ALLIANCE WITH KEY PLAYERS IN THE
MEXICAN HYDROCARBON -- SECTOR
WITH THE SUPPORT OF THE MEXICAN
GOVERNMENT YOU MAY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WE CONDUCTED A WORKSHOP
ON SUSTAINABILITY OF THE HOW TO
COVER CARBON VALUE CHAIN IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THEM MEXICAN
INSTITUTE OF PETROLEUM.
WE PRODUCE ARE PRODUCED A REPORT
ON THE NATIONAL PRIORITIES FOR
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT IN IN
THIS AREA.
THE MEXICAN GOVERNMENT LUNCH A
CALL FOR PROPOSALS THROUGH
THROUGH ITS NATIONAL COUNCIL FOR
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY AND THE
MINISTRY OF ENERGY --
HYDROCARBONSFUND I CONSORTIUM
LED BY THE TECHNOLOGICAL
INSTITUTE OF MONTEREY THE
NATIONAL INSTEAD OF PETROLEUM
AND THE NATIONAL UNIVERSITY OF
MEXICO WHAT'S THE NAME OF THE
POTENTIAL LEAD FOR THE CREATION
OF A RESEARCH CENTER -- IN IN IN
IN A STRATEGIC ALLIANCE WITH
STAFF.
FOR WE HOPE TO HELP MEXICO LEAP
FROG AND MOTHER'S MODERNIZE ITS
OIL AND GAS INDUSTRY YOU TO ONE
OF THE CLEANEST OPERATIONS IN
THE WORLD.
BUT ALSO REFERRED ITS
HYDROCARBON VALUE CHAIN FOR THE
TRANSITION TO A LOW CARBON
ECONOMY.
SENATE THOUGH SENATOR BEN HUESO.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A GLOBAL
LEADER IN CLIMATE ACTION.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS THE GLOBAL
CHALLENGE WE HAVE WE CAN HELP
OTHER COUNTRIES THAT THAT THEIR
NATIONAL CLIMATE AMBITION WITH
INSTITUTIONAL COOPERATION
CAPACITY BUILDING.
MEXICO IS OUR NEIGHBOR AND
SHOULD BE A PRIORITY ON HOW
CALIFORNIA INTERACTS WITH THE
WORLD IN THIS AREA.
THERE ARE.
ALSO MAJOR COMPETITIVENESS AND
ECONOMIC BENEFITS BY FOSTERING A
GROWING BI NATIONAL ECONOMY THAT
SUPPORTS LOW CARBON DEVELOPMENT
IN OUR REGION.
STAFFERS RECORDINGS Và DID FOR
ENERGY AND A SPECTACLE CLEAN
ECONOMY TWENTY FIFTY PROGRAM ARE
READY TO ENHANCE OUR PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE STATE IN MEETING THIS
AMBITIOUS GOALS.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OF THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU [inaudible]
FOR SCHERING.
BUT LOTS OF GOOD INFORMATION
LESS AND I WANNA BEGIN BY
THANKING ALL THE ALL THE
PANELISTS OR CONTRIBUTED TO THIS
EFFORT.
DID THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
WANT TO MAKE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS OR SIR BRADFORD AYE I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
FOR CONVENING THIS HEARING AND I
THINK IF IT'S ONE TAKE AWAY
WE'LL.
AND ALL UNDERSTAND THAT WE HAVE
FAR MORE.
IN COMMON WITH MEXICO THAN WE
HAVE DIFFERENCES AND I THINK
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE AS
CALIFORNIANS SHOW THE LEAD AS IT
RELATES TO THE ECONOMY AND THE
ENVIRONMENT.
AND ABD AND SHOW WHAT DIRECT
IMPACT IT HAS ON BOTH COUNTRIES
BECAUSE IN MANY WAYS WERE ONE
COUNTRY -- DESPITE MUCH OF OUR
DIFFERENCES WE HAVE BEEN --
INTERDEPENDENCY THAT'S FAR
BEYOND JUST.
THE PEOPLE THAT CROSS THE BORDER
SO I THANK YOU FOR THIS I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNMENT AND THE INSTITUTIONS
OF THEIR AND HIGHER EDUCATION
ALSO IN ADDRESSING.
THESE CONCERNS AND THESE ISSUES
THAT AGAIN IMPACT BOTH COUNTRIES
TREMENDOUSLY SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP.
THANK CENTER AROUND WHY DOES THE
I'D LOVE TO BUY ONE OF THESE I
WANT TO ASK ABOUT A MAYBE DOCTOR
STARRED OCCURS YEARLY.
I THE LAST TIME I WAS IN MEXICO
WE TRAVEL TOGETHER I IT WAS
DURING THE TWENTY SIXTEEN SUMMER.
TWENTY SIXTEEN I AND SO I
HAVEN'T BEEN IN MEXICO SINCE A
DOG JUMP SELECT A PRESIDENT.
IT'S INTERESTING TO HEAR THE YOU
KNOW WHEN WE WERE THERE.
PEOPLE WERE VERY VERY WORRIED
ABOUT -- HIS CANDIDACY IN COURSE
WE SPENT ALL TIME SAYING THAT
DOG DOOR IS NOT GOING TO WIN --
NEVER THINGS CAN BE JUST FINE
AND AND SO.
REALLY I MEAN I WAS THAT WAS
KIND OF A MESSAGE ON NATIONAL
ABOUT EARLY IN RETROSPECT BUT
YOU KNOW LOVE TO HEAR YOU
OBVIOUSLY AFTER THE INITIAL.
REACTION THERE SEEMS TO BE A
CERTAIN COMING TO TERMS MAYBE
I'M A LOT OF AMERICANS ARE ARE
IN THE SAME BOAT.
AB I LOVE TO GET SOME INSIGHTS
INTO THE CURRENT POLITICAL
CLIMATE AS IT RELATES TO THE
TRUMP PRESIDENCY HOW HE'S VIEWED
HOW THE HOW HOW THINGS HAVE
EVOLVED OVER THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS -- AND AND HOW THAT'S MAY
BE REFLECTED BY THE ELECTION
RESULTS BUT I I KNOW OUR EXPERTS
ARE HERE LET ME START MADE SOME
COMMENTS REGARDING THAT I THINK
THEY WERE THEY WERE GOOD IN
TERMS OF HER ANALYSIS OF
MEXICO'S POLITICAL POSITIONS
WITH THIS ADMINISTRATION BUT IF
YOU WANT EXPAND.
COM UM I MEAN PUBLIC OPINION OF
OF OF OF OF TRUMP IN MEXICO IS
EXTREMELY POOR I DON'T HAVE THE
NUMBERS IN FRONT OF ME.
BUT I WAS A POSITIVE OPINION OF
HIM IS PROBABLY IN SINGLE DIGITS --
BUT AS I SAID IN MY COMMENTS
MEXICAN SEPARATE OUT THEIR
ATTITUDES TOWARD PRESIDENT TRUMP
FROM THEIR ATTITUDES TOWARDS
UNITED STATES.
SENATORS TOWARDS UNITED STATES
ACTUALLY STILL QUITE STRONG.
I'M IN THERE STILL IS A STRONG --
SUPPORT FOR THE NORTH AMERICAN
FREE TRADE AGREEMENT.
AND THEIR STRONG SUPPORT FOR
AWHILE WILL MEXICANS ARE VERY
CRITICAL OF PRESIDENT BEEN AND
YET THE FOR NOT RESPONDING. TO
TRUMP'S PROVOCATIONS THEY SEEM
TO HAVE TURNED -- THEIR ATTITUDE
SIGNIFICANTLY AT OUR BACKING
LOPEZ OBRADOR'S STRATEGY OF
SIMPLY NOT RESPONDING -- THERE
SEEMS TO BE THIS THE GENERAL
ATTITUDE THAT -- IF YOU NOTICE
WANTS TO BUILD A WALL WHATEVER
BUILD A WALL.
OF BOUGHT -- WHAT IS THE BEST
WAY TO OF THEM TO DEAL WITH
UNITED STATES IS TO NOT CONFRONT
PROP TRUMP AND NOT BECAUSE
ADDITIONAL PROBLEMS WITH THEM
BECAUSE YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT THE
NEXT WEEK IT'S GOING TO BE? ONE
TWEET AS I LEFT MEXICO ON THE
NEXT STREET IS MEXICO'S THE
CAUSE OF ALL OF OUR PROBLEMS.
SO IN GENERAL THERE'S IS AS
BROAD ATTITUDE OF JUST NOT
DEALING WITH HIM AND LETTING HIM
THEIR SPIN HIMSELF.
ALLEN ANY IN IS THAT THAT'S SORT
OF THAT THAT THERE IS THAT'S AN
EVOLUTION OF SORTS FROM THE
BEGINNING FROM FOR WHEN HE WAS
FIRST ELECTED.
WHEN TROUBLES A SELECTION YEAH
OF THERE WAS A LOT OF CRITICISM
OF PRESIDENT BEEN AND YET THE
FOR NOT STANDING UP MORE
STRONGLY TO TRUMP?
AND THERE WAS A BELIEF THAT
LOPEZ OBRADOR WAS ACTUALLY GOING
TO BE MORE FORCEFUL ANY ACTUALLY
PUBLISHED A BOOK DURING THE
CAMPAIGN CALLED OR YET TRUMP.
AND WHICH HE CRITICIZED US
POLICY AGGRESSIVELY AND THERE
WAS THE ASSUMPTION THAT THERE
WAS GOING TO BE A LARGE CLASH
BETWEEN THE TWO OF THEM -- BUT
WHEN LOCUSTS OVER THE WAR HAD TO
DECIDE DID HE WANT TO SPEND HIS
TIME CONFRONTING UNITED STATES
OR CONFRONTING THE ECONOMIC
PROBLEMS THAT HE SEES IN MEXICO
HE CHOSE THE LATTER.
AND I THINK PART OF IT IS
BECAUSE HE'S SO DARN POPULAR HIS.
HIS APPROVAL RATINGS ARE IN THE
MID SEVENTIES -- THAT THE
POPULATION IS GIVING HIM THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT BACKING HIM
ON THIS POLICY ERIDGE NOW WE ARE
WE ACTUALLY WANT A LISTING US
RIGHT AFTER THE TRUMP MEETING
AND WE HAD A CHANCE TO TALK.
TO AND PRESIDENT BEING AT ABOUT
IT WAS VERY INTERESTING READING
ON'T.
YOUR OTHER QUESTION WANT TO ASK
YOU THERE'S BEEN AT AS WAS
MENTIONED A KIND OF A EARTHQUAKE
ELECTORALLY.
IN A SIMILAR TO WHAT WE'VE SEEN
WHEN FRANCE AND AND A COUPLE
OTHER PLACES WHERE THE
TRADITIONAL PARTY STRUCTURE HAS
RUPTURED -- YOU HAVE THIS.
YEAH BRAND NEW PARTY THAT IS
SEEMINGLY COME OUT OF NOWHERE
VERY CLOSE ASSOCIATE WITH THIS
ONE PERSON.
I'M CAN YOU CAN YOU GIVE US SOME
INSIGHTS AS TO HOW WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT THE POLITICAL SCENE
IN MEXICO RIGHT NOW IN THE WAKE
OF THE ELECTIONS AND
UNDERSTANDING THOSE RESULTS.
SURE I MEAN THE THE RESULTS
THEMSELVES A REFLECTION OF THE
DISSATISFACTION THAT MEXICO'S
FELT TOWARD TRADITIONAL
POLITICAL PARTIES.
WHAT'S INTERESTING IS THAT --
LOCUS OF A LOWER DID NOT CHANGE
HIS OPINIONS AND THE MULTIPLE
TIMES THAT HE RUN FOR PRESIDENT
WHAT CHANGED WAS PUBLIC OPINION
ATTITUDES TOWARD THE OPPOSITION
AND THEREFORE TOWARD HIM.
AND WE GOT TO ELECTION IN TWO
TWENTY SIX IN IN IN IN IN --
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AGAIN MY YEARS
RIGHT -- THAT -- LEVELS OF A
LOWER WAS SEEN AS THE BEST
OPTION AVAILABLE WE TRIED TO PUT
THE THE BOND FOR FOR TWELVE
YEARS.
AND THEY HAD NO PROOF THING
SIGNIFICANTLY INDEED THINGS THAT
WE ECONOMY SEEM TO BE QUITE
STAGNANT.
WITHIN TRY THE PREVIEW PROMISED
A INCREASE GROWTH IN WHAT THEY
GAVE US WAS A DRAMATIC INCREASE
IN CORRUPTION AND NO INCREASE IN
GROWTH -- AND AND IN BOTH CASES
SECURITY KEPT GETTING WORSE AND
WORSE AND WORSE SO WHY NOT TRY
THE OTHER OPTION WE HAVEN'T
TRIED -- IN THERE WAS A LOT OF
OF OF ABOUT 20% OF THE VOTE FOR
OF VOTERS IN MEXICO WHICH IS.
I'VE MOVED UP SOME OF THE OR
FROM 3250% OF THE ELECTRICITY 3%
HE WON SORT OF WERE IN THAT
POSITIONOF WE'RE SO DISGUSTED
WITH THE OTHER TWO PARTIES THAT
WE'RE GONNA GIVE HIM A TRY YEAH --
AND THE OTHER TWO PARTIES HAVE
IMPLODED TO A CERTAIN TO TRIP
PORTENT AGREE THERE ARE THERE
ARE THE PRE AND THE AND THE PIER
DEAR SHADOWS OF WHICH THEY ONCE
WERE.
AND THE BOND IS ALSO QUITE WEAK
SO THE SITUATION IN MEXICO NOW
IS ONE OF A OF A A COUNTRY IN
WHICH GIVE A VERY VERY POPULAR
PRESIDENT TO CONTROLS BOTH
HOUSES OF THE LEGISLATURE.
AND DOESN'T HAVE A STRONG
OPPOSITION THE DOESN'T CONTROL
TWO THIRDS OF THE SENATE -- BUT
THE UP THE THE OPPOSITION THAT
IS THERE TO OPPOSE HIM IS IS
QUITE WEAK -- AND SO HE IS A
VERY STRONG PRESIDENT AS A
RESULT.
OR MY HOW QUESTION ALLIANCES MY
ROOMMATE YOU HAVE MY FINAL
QUESTION -- WHAT'S THE STATE OF
PLAY OF DRUG LEGALIZATION --
THAT CONVERSATION IN MEXICO
RIGHT NOW AND WE'RE OBVIOUSLY
MOVING WONDER ACTION I WAS
INITIALLY CAME UP IN A
CONVERSATION WITH THE PRESIDENT.
WHEN WE WERE DOWN THERE -- WHERE
ATTITUDES WHERE YOU SEE THAT
CONVERSATION MEXICO'S MOVING IN
THE SAME DIRECTION?
IT'S IT'S IT'S IT'S A LITTLE BIT
BEHIND THE UNITED STATES BUT%
THERE WAS JUST A PROPOSAL.
I AND I DON'T REMEMBER -- WHERE
THE PROPOSAL WAS WHICH HAS THE
LEGISLATURE THERE'S BEEN A
PROPOSAL TO LEGALIZE MARIJUANA
IN MEXICO?
AND IN THE CONGRESS RIGHT NOW
IT'S A I BELIEVE SO IS THAT
RIGHT.
YES EXACTLY YEAH YOU GET THE BY
CHANCE AT THE NAY [inaudible]
IS THERE.
HAS BEEN RECOGNIZE HIS VISIT
STRAIGHT LEGALIZATION YES THE
YEAH.
I'M OKAY THAT IS THEIR EDITOR
OKAY THAT'S VERY INTERESTING I
MEAN I YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY -- AND
THEN THEN IT IS JUST IS JUST
pYES AND WILL BE STRAIGHT
RECREATIONAL USE AND YEAH OKAY.
THE DAHLE USING AN YEAH RIGHT
OKAY THANK YOU FOR YOU FOR BEING
HERE AND EVERYONE ELSE
PARTICIPATED I JUST BEFORE WE GO
TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
I JUST WANNA -- THANK ALEXIS
KOSTROMA OFFICE FOR DOING A
GREAT JOB PUTTING THIS TOGETHER.
ALSO REFERED TIDY REAL FAST.
THAT MEANS YOUR CAUSE WITH THE
LESSONS IN AN INTERNATIONAL FOR
BEING HERE AND PARTICIPATING
HELPING US PUT THIS TOGETHER.
THE YREKA CENTER FOR POLICY
RESEARCH OR ARE CONSTRUED.
ILEANA FEDERAL THANK YOU.
FOR ALL YOUR HELP ON US MINUTE
THANK ARE THE ONLY MEMBER TONY
VASQUEZ. FOR PARTICIPATE TODAY
FOR BEING HERE -- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- FOR I HAVE IT ALLOWING
US TO HAVE THIS OF PUBLIC
CONVERSATION.
WE WANT TO HEAR FROM SOME
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IF YOU
WANT TO COME FORWARD TO THE MIKE.
YES SIR DID YOU HAVE SOMETHING
TO SAY.
THAT JUST COME TO THE MIKE AND
MAKE A FEW.
BRIEF COMMENTS IF YOU WILL --
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
PUBLIC ITHINK -- COMMENT ON ALL
TAKE YOUR HUESO -- MOTOROLA
FEDERATED.
OF FOR YOUR VACATION -- ACTUALLY --
I WAS AWARE OF THIS BY A DOCTOR
WHO SAID LANDES WITH MY PARTNER
MEXICO AND YOU WERE TO TALK
ABOUT THAT.
BUT I THINK THE KEY WORD HERE
IT'S CONFIDENCE [inaudible]
I BELIEVE.
I'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR FORTY
FIVE YEARS.
BI NATIONAL INVESTOR.
PROMOTING INVESTMENT TO MEXICO
FOR FORTY FIVE YEARS.
AND I'VE NEVER SEEN THE
CONFIDENCE LEVEL AS IT IS TODAY
SOMETHING IS WHAT YOU'RE READING
THE NEWS.
SOMETHING OF A TAB REALLY
HAPPENING.
THE BI NATIONAL BUSINESS NOW A
WE HAVE AN INDUSTRIAL PARK WITH
THIRTY SEVEN US CORPORATIONS.
BUT A MILLION SQUARE FEET BUT
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE THOUSAND
WORKERS.
THEY'RE ALL COMPLIMENTING UNITED
STATES MANUFACTURERS MOST OF
THEM COMING FROM CHINA.
BACK TO UNITED STATES BE UP
MEXICALI WHICH IS MY CITY.
I'M NOT GOVERNMENT WERE PRIVATE.
ED CHAU ARE DID WANT TO SAY THIS.
TO DATE NO PERSONAL WHAT OTHER
WATER THE PRESIDENT OF MEXICO
AND I'M A BIT IS WHAT I'M.
p[inaudible]
HAS.
HAS ESTABLISH A CONFIDENCE LEVEL
THIS UNIQUE.
THE K. FILLABLE WE ASKED WE
SPEAK WE'RE DEALING WITH NEW
COMPANIES COMING TO MEXICO
ESPECIALLY IN THEIR FACE TO
COMPANIES [inaudible]
ALSO [inaudible]
TRUMP.
HESS BUILT CONFIDENCE LEVEL TO
BRING MORE COMPANY CHAU TOM
BELIEVABLE.
SHOW TO ME AND I WANT TO SAY
THIS TO ALL OF YOU.
HERE IS THE CONFIDENCE LEVEL IS
THERE.
AND WE SEE CHANGES ANY CHANGES
IN A CUSTOM FOR INSTANCE -- IN
MEXICALI.
LE HANDLE WE DON'T WANT THIS.
HE'S DOING A EXCELLENT JOB HE IS
GOING TO EVERYBODY LIKE ME.
IN NOTHING BEFORE.
HE'S COMING IS HUMBLE EIGHTY SAY
NO MORE CORRUPTION.
IN IN THE VITAMIN HE KILEY WE
NEED TO SHARE FOR YA.
AND CONNECT TO LOOK AT I LOVE
WHAT YOU SAID.
CONNECT TO CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN SAYS THE
COMMISSION OF THE CALIFORNIA.
WHAT RONALD REAGAN AS GOVERNOR
I'VE BEEN INVOLVED WITH WITH ALL
THAT BUT KND MEANWHILE HOT
GOING TO REMEMBER YOU BROUGHT IT?
THE THE FIRST -- IT WITH
SOMEBODY BUT I TELL YOU WE NEED
TO RETAKE.
REGROUP.
AND PUT TOGETHER A PROGRAM BUT
HOW CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA CHAU
NORA.
YUMA ARIZONA THANK YOU REALLY
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR COMMENTS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN A
MEMBER SO SAID MATT AND I ON
BEHALF OF WORLDWIDE
ENVIRONMENTAL PRODUCTS HERE
TODAY -- I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR FOR HAVING THIS HEARING --
AND FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON IN
CALIFORNIA AND SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC ENGAGEMENT WITH MEXICO
WORLDWIDE ENVIRONMENTAL PRODUCTS
INK IS A CALIFORNIA FAMILY OWNED
AND OPERATED SMALL TO MEDIUM
SIZE ENTERPRISE THAT DESIGNS.
DEVELOPS IMPLEMENTS OPERATES AND
SERVICES VARIOUS TYPES OF MOTOR
VEHICLE EMISSIONS AND SAFETY
INSPECTION PROGRAMS AROUND THE
WORLD.
FROM THE INSPECTION EQUIPMENT
DESIGN AND MAINTENANCE TO
DATABASE MANAGEMENT QUALITY
CONTROL AND ASSURANCE TO
PERSONAL TRAINING.
WORLDWIDE PROVIDES TURNKEY
SOLUTIONS FOR THE SUCCESSFUL
MANAGEMENT OPERATION A VEHICLE
INSPECTION PROGRAMS ALL OUT OF
ITS HEADQUARTERS IN BREA
CALIFORNIA.
IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO MEXICO
CITY IMPLEMENTED A MANDATORY
VEHICLE EMISSIONS TESTING
PROGRAM AND AT THAT TIME THE
UNITED NATIONS DESCRIBE MEXICO
CITY'S AIR.
AS THE MOST POLLUTED ON THE
PLANET WORLDWIDE WAS PART OF THE
CONSORTIUM THAT BUILT THE FIRST
VEHICLE EMISSIONS INSPECTION
CENTER IN MEXICO.
IN ADDITION WORLDWIDE HAS BEEN A
CERTIFIED AND EQUIPMENT PROVIDER
IN THE CURRENT VEHICLE
INSPECTION PROGRAM IN THE STATE
OF JALISCO SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHT A SOLE SOURCE
TECHNOLOGY PROVIDER CONSISTS OF
NOT ONLY SUPPLYING INSPECTION
EQUIPMENT TO THE INSPECTION
STATIONS BUT ALSO.
A DATABASE MANAGEMENT AND SUITE
OF SOFTWARE APPLICATIONS WHICH
PROVIDE THE GOVERNMENT WITH
TOOLS TO PROPERLY MANAGE THE
VEHICLE INSPECTION PROGRAMME IN
REAL TIME.
THE VEHICLE EMISSIONS INSPECTION
PROGRAM IN AT LEAST GO PROVIDES
A TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY TO EARN
AND MAINTAIN AN EXCLUSIVE
CONTRACT FOR FIFTEEN YEARS.
AGAIN ON BEHALF OF WORLDWIDE
ENVIRONMENTAL PRODUCTS I WANT TO
THANK YOU CHAIR FOR HAVING THIS
HEARING TODAY YOUR OBJECTIVES
AND INTENTIONS IT SHOULD CLEARLY
DEMONSTRATE TO THE COUNTRY OF
MEXICO THAT CALIFORNIA IS
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING.
ENGAGEMENT AND FACILITATING
POSITIVE RELATIONS BETWEEN
BUSINESSES AND GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES ON BOTH SIDE OF THE
BORDER.
IT'S IT IS CRITICAL IN THIS FALL
TÁI POLITICAL CRIME CLIMB IT
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL HOPEFULLY
THIS PERCEPTION AND COMMITMENT
FROM CALIFORNIA WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA BASED BUSINESSES LIKE
WORLDWIDE. TO CONTINUE TO BE
SELECTED OVER INTERNATIONAL
COMPETITORS IN MEXICO LIKE THE
MODEL IN JALISCO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE TIME THANK YOU.
SEVEN OBERNOLTE FROM UC BERKELEY --
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I
JUST AND I REALLY LIKE THE
PANELS THAT -- SPOKE TO
PREVIOUSLY AND INCLUDED A COUPLE
OF ACADEMICS.
AND I JUST WANNA AT ONE POINT TO
THE POINTS THAT THEY MADE.
I DON'T KNOW IF THE NUMBERS ARE
EXACTLY RIGHT BUT PEOPLE SAY THE
TIME IS TEN TIMES THE SIZE OF
MEXICO BUT SENDS A HUNDRED TIMES
AS MANY STUDENTS TO CALIFORNIA --
THEY ENRICH OUR ECONOMY THEY
ENRICH OUR SOCIETY AND THEY
CERTAINLY IMPROVE.
A COLLABORATION WITH CHINA SOUTH
ASIA SIMILARLY SENDS A LARGE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS AND SILICON
VALLEY BENEFITS FROM FROM THEIR
BRAIN POWER.
WE DON'T DO NEARLY ENOUGH WITH
MEXICO AND IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
AS PART OF THIS OF AN INITIATIVE
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WE NEED
TO SEND MORE CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
TO MEXICO TO STUDY.
AND WE TO BRING MORE MEXICAN
STUDENTS TO CALIFORNIA TO STUDY
AND WE NEED TO DO THAT CONNECTS
FROM WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
I THINK THAT'S TRUE OF THE UC
SYSTEM BUT IT'S ALSO TRUE CAL
STATE IT'S ALSO TRUE OF OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
WE NEED A REAL EFFORT TO
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF FLOW BACK
AND FORTH -- THAT IS ACADEMIC
AND FOCUS ESPECIALLY ON THE
ENTREPRENEURIAL SIDE NOW WE WANT
TO GET STUDENTS WHO ARE HAVING
NOT JUST ACADEMIC BUT ALSO WORK
EXPERIENCES ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
BORDER. TO INCREASE THAT
COLLABORATION THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON -- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IT'S A PRIVILEGE TO BE
HERE TODAY SENATOR WESSEL -- I
AM REALLY HAPPY TO COME HERE
THIS MY FIRST TIME HERE AT THE
CAPITOL.
I VISITED SACRAMENTO BEFORE BUT
NOT THE CAPITAL AND ACTUALLY
WANTED TO ADD A LITTLE TO THE
CONVERSATION I FOUND THIS --
MEETING TODAY EXTREMELY -- LET
EVERYONE KNOW WHO YOU ARE.
I'M FROM CALEXICO I WAS BORN IN
CALEXICO RAISING CALEXICO IN A
BEEN A BUSINESS WOMAN THERE. FOR
OVER THIRTY TWO YEARS BUT I
THINK THAT I HAVE A LITTLE BIT
YOUR NAME YOUR NAME.
MY NAME IS MONEY TO TELL THE
VETERAN.
AND THE REASON I THINK I WANTED
TO SPEAK TODAY WAS BECAUSE I
KIND OF HAVE A LITTLE BIT TO SAY
TO ALL OF YOU THAT DO SO MUCH
FOR COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE -- ALL
OF YOU KNOW THAT WE HAVE BEEN.
THE FOCUS OF A LOT OF THE NEWS
LATELY CNN HAS BEEN VISITING IS
WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP CAME TO
CALEXICO IN.
AND DONE IT WAS EXTREMELY
EXCRUCIATING THESE FRUSTRATING
TO SEE WHAT IT IS THAT HAPPENED --
WE REALLY WANTED THE COMMUNITY
TO BE -- KNOWN AS A FRIENDLY
COMMUNITY OF A COMMUNITY OF
COOPERATION WITH THE CITY OF
MEXICALI WHICH WE HAVE
CONSISTENTLY HAD AS A ALL THESE
YEARS AS A SISTER CITY
RELATIONSHIP.
VERY STRONG WHEN.
BUT I THINK I ALSO WANT TO TELL
YOU ALL THAT I'M KIND OF A
DOUBLE TROUBLE OR OR OR DOUBLE
WHAMMY SITUATION IN THIS
CONVERSATION BECAUSE MY FAMILY --
HAS LOST LOVED ONES TO THE NEW
RIVER -- MY MOTHER WORKED IN A
SAFE WAY THAT WAS -- PROBABLY
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED FEET FROM THE
NEW RIVER WHICH AT THIS POINT
CALEXICO JUST BUILT.
A NEW -- VEHICULAR -- ENTRANCE
OF NEW PORT OF ENTRY.
RIGHT NEXT TO THAT RIVER AND AS
IT WAS BEING BUILT I DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND WHY IT WASN'T GONNA
BE ENCASED.
AND SO MY MOTHER PASSED AWAY
HAVE MY BEST FRIEND HERE SHE'S
ON A CANCER SURVIVOR AND SO MY
I'M A SEVENTEEN YEAR CANCER
SURVIVORS IT HAPPENED TO ME WHEN
I WAS THIRTY SIX YEARS OLD.
AND HER MOTHER ALSO.
IS A PASSED AWAY OF BREAST
CANCER.
THEY LIVE HAVE A BLOCK AWAY FROM
THE NEW RIVER SO.
AS A BUSINESS WOMAN.
WHEN TRUMP CAME TO CLICKS AGO
THOSE FIRST DAYS OF APRIL -- IT
FELT HORRIBLE TO KNOW THAT THERE
WAS A THREAT.
THAT PANICKED EVERYONE IT WAS.
SOMETHING THAT MEANT TO US THAT
OUR CITY WAS BASICALLY GOING TO
BE SHUT DOWN.
IN THE CITY OF CALEXICO OF
COURSE COMPLETELY.
RECOGNIZES RESPECTS AND THE
DOORS OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH
MEXICO.
IT IS A NATURAL RELATIONSHIP IT
IS A FUN RELATIONSHIP -- I KNOW
THAT THERE'S GOING TO POSSIBLY
BE A CHANGE OF ADMINISTRATION
BUT THAT WILL ALWAYS ALWAYS
CONTINUE.
SO MUCH ALL TO KNOW THAT THE
HARD WORK THAT YOU ALL DO TO
HEAR THAT SOME DAY I HOPE THAT
THE FACT THAT I'M STILL THE
SURVIVOR.
EVEN THOUGH LIVING IN THIS
COMMUNITY HAS DONE SO MUCH TO ME
PERSONALLY.
BUT I CAN ALSO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY COME BACK AND JOIN
YOU ON AND DO THE SAME WORK FOR
OUR COMMUNITY.
BECAUSE COMMUNITIES LIKE OURS
THEY THEY'RE VERY UNIQUE BUT THE
VERY SPECIAL.
TO AND SO THE REASON WHY PEOPLE
LIKE OURSELVES THE LIVING THERE
IS TO HELP OUR HINTED.
AND HELPS TO CONTINUE
PROGRESSING SO I WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY WAS
AWESOME.
AND THANK YOU SENATOR I HOPE YOU
ONCE AGAIN COME VISIT US TO
THANK YOU AND WELCOME TO THE
SECOND.
THANK YOU FOR MAKING COMMENTS.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
AND IF I COULD JUST MAKE SOME
CLOSING COMMENTS -- YOU KNOW
WHAT.
AS AS AS WELL AS WITNESS HERE BY
THE THE THE WONDERFUL RESOURCES
THAT WE AVE IN THE AND THE THE
PANEL THAT WE PUT TOGETHER TODAY.
YOU KNOW I I I JUST HAVE
COMPLETE CONFIDENCE THAT WE HAVE
THE TALENT HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WITHIN OUR OWN COMMUNITY. TO
HELP US.
IMPROVE OUR OUR OUR RELATIONSHIP
WITH MEXICO AND HELP BUILD ON IT
AND HELP.
STRENGTHEN ALL ASPECTS OF HOW WE
INTERACT AS AS AS PEOPLE AS AS
AS A AS COUNTRIES.
THE I. THAT'S WHY I'M PROPOSING
THE THE COMMISSION FOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA'S BECAUSE I'VE SEEN
SO MANY PEOPLE AT AT THE
COMMUNITY LEVEL.
BUILD -- SISTER STATE OR SISTER
A CITY RELATIONSHIPS ARE
BUILDING.
CLUBS THAT REPRESENT DIFFERENT --
CITIES IN MEXICO AND THEY'RE
PROMOTING -- THOSE CITIES IN
MEXICO HERE CALIFORNIAN I JUST
SEE.
WONDERFUL WORK THIS TAKING PLACE
IN OUR COMMUNITY MORE COULD BE
DONE THROUGH AN OUT AN OFFICIAL
[inaudible]
ORGANIZATION.
AND OF IN THE AREA OF EDUCATION
I AGREE.
THERE IS SO MUCH MORE THAT WE
NEED TO DO TO SEND.
OUR STUDENTS TO MEXICO AND TO
RECEIVE A STUDENTS FROM MEXICO
HERE CALIFORNIA BECAUSE AGAIN
THERE IS SO MUCH POTENTIAL IN US
WORKING TOGETHER IN ALL THOSE
AREAS BUT ALL OUR PROBLEMS COULD
BE SOLVED.
WITH INFORMATION WITH EDUCATION
WITH TECHNOLOGY AND BUILDING ON
THAT AND INTRODUCING NEW
TECHNOLOGIES [inaudible]
I'VE BEEN.
REALLY ENCOURAGE WITH SOME OF
THE IN TOUCH TECHNOLOGY TO BEING.
DEVELOPED IN MEXICO.
AND COMING TO CALIFORNIA SOLVE
PROBLEMS AND AND AND THE AND THE
AND THE OPPOSITE AS WELL.
IT TECHNOLOGIES BEING DEVELOPED
IN CALIFORNIA BEEN INTRODUCED
MEXICO IN IN MANY DIFFERENT
AREAS CALIFORNIA HAS A MEXICO'S
A WEALTH OF EXPERTISE IN AREAS
OF AGRICULTURE.
AND AND NEW INNOVATIVE
AGRICULTURAL TECHNIQUES THAT ARE
ALSO BEING EMPLOYED IN
CALIFORNIA AND LIKEWISE.
AND THERE IS A NEW PROGRAM AND
I'D LIKE TO KIND OF MAKE THIS
ANNOUNCEMENT BECAUSE I THINK.
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS FOR KIDS IN
THE AGES OF EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
FIVE TO PARTICIPATE IN A REALLY
EXCITING PROGRAM THAT THE IS.
THE EMAIL AND MEXICO THE IS TO
FOR MEXICO THIS LIVING ABROAD --
THEY ARE FUNDING A PROGRAM THAT
WILL TAKE TWO HUNDRED
CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS TO STUDY
IN MEXICO THIS SUMMER.
AND THEY WILL -- ARE NOT ONLY BE
ABLE TO VISIT.
MEXICO CITY AND SOME OF THE
CULTURAL RESOURCES BUT STUDY
ABROAD AND ALSO PROVIDE
VOLUNTEER SERVICE.
IN A TOWN WHERE -- THEY MAY HAVE
SOME -- YOU KNOW RELATIVES OR
THEY HAVE YOU KNOW SOME.
OR A TIME THAT THEY'VE BEEN
SOMEBODY IN THE FAMILY WAS
ASSOCIATED WITH A SOME POINT.
AND I THINK THAT'S WONDERFUL
OPPORTUNITY FOR THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE AND I THINK THIS
INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE THROUGH
EMAIL AND THE THE CONSULATES.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF PEOPLE
WANNA PARTICIPATE IT'S AN
APPLICATION PROCESS THEY'VE A
SELECTION PROCESS.
BUT IT'S A KIND INITIATIVE THAT
WE NEED AND I APPRECIATE.
MEXICO TAKING THE INITIATIVE TO
OFFER THIS PROGRAM TO STUDENTS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA BUT WE ALSO
DO NEED TO DO THE SAME.
WE ALSO NEED TO OFFER.
THOSE EXCHANGES WE HAVE TO BUILD
CULTURAL COMPETENCY WE HAVE TO
BUILD BUSINESS ACCU MEANT.
WE HAVE TO ALSO ENCOURAGE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF OF OF OF OF A
LANGUAGE AND BRIDGING THE
LANGUAGE GAPS BETWEEN OUR
RESPECTIVE SOCIETIES.
AND ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO US STUDY
ENGLISH AND SPANISH [inaudible]
AND ANY OTHER LANGUAGE OR HELP
THEM BUILD OF THE THE ACCU MEANT
TO TO IMPROVE THIS DIALOGUE.
WHICH IS OUR OUR BUSINESS AND
CULTURAL EXCHANGES SO.
UP FOLLOWING THIS WE WILL -- I
WILL BE GOING TO THE THE
STANFORD MANSION FOR THE MEXICO
OUT OF IT BECAUSE HE'S DAY
CELEBRATION ALL SEE ALL OF YOU
THERE -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ALLOWING US -- TO HAVE THIS A
PUBLIC CONVERSATION AND SURE.
ALL ALL THIS INFORMATION WITH
THE PEOPLE OF OUR STATE
HOPEFULLY.
IT'LL BUILD ON THIS DIALOGUE
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO CREATE AN
ILL. ONE DAY TRANSLATE INTO GOOD
PUBLIC POLICY TO HELP BRING US
CLOSER TO OUR ALLY TO THE SOUTH.
MEXICO THANK YOU VERY MUCH LAYS
IN TERMS